Ihr hört CRE Technik Kultur Gesellschaft mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und nach einer längeren Pause geht's hier endlich wieder weiter bei CAE,
Ausgabe Nummer 219 steht an,
und ja wie schon erwähnt ich habe mir ein bisschen Zeit gelassen weil das Programm.
Ja immer versucht sowohl die besonderen Themen vielleicht zu verorten und das manchmal gar nicht so einfach da einerseits auf das richtige Thema zu kommen voran die richtigen Gesprächspartner zu finden und dann auch noch ein Tee,
das kann sich manchmal ganz schön ziehen so war es auch bei dem Thema was wir heute in Angriff nehmen wollen.
Müssen sprechen über Partys Partykultur und mal ganz speziell auch über die Party Kultur die sich in Deutschland und Europa so seit den 90er Jahren entwickelt hat.
Und dazu begrüße ich erstmal mein Gesprächspartner nämlich den andre hallo Andre.
Nein wir kennen uns jetzt schon eine Weile.
Ja das kann man so sagen.
Haben auch so das eine oder andere zusammen befeuert auch schon organisiert.
Also wenn mal sicherlich am Rande auch noch mal so drauf kommen aber du bist ja sehr viel tiefer verortet der viel tiefer drin.
Damals und wie auch heute noch bis selber Party Veranstalter Barbetreiber,
also hast du sagen viel Erfahrung viel gesehen und viel gemacht und steckst mit beiden Armen tief drin in der Bespaßung von Leuten kann man sagen.
Kann man so sagen mache ich jetzt inzwischen seit fast 30 Jahren also professionell seit 25 Jahren semiprofessionell seit 30 Jahren aber,
eigentlich auch schon deutlich viel länger wenn ich jetzt mal die Zeit dazu nehme wo ich das nicht mit einem oder wo ich das einfach aus der.
Eigenen aus der eigenen Intuition gemacht habe auf Partys zu gehen weil das mache ich eigentlich seitdem ich 14 15 Jahre alt bin und inzwischen bin ich deutlich älter also sehr sehr lange in diesem,
business.
Gut auf Party gehen das haben wir alle schon mal gemacht aber wann hat sich denn das erste Mal getrieben so ein bisschen die Seite zu wechseln also muss ja auch unseren Antrieb geben dass man denkt so das müsste ich jetzt eigentlich auch mal machen.
Du das allererste Mal muss ich sagen war eigentlich direkt mit meinem Abitur und der Abiturfeier,
wo ich mich dazu berufen fühlte den gebuchten DJ ein wenig zu unterstützen und das hat auch ganz gut funktioniert
und später dann mit meinem also ich bin kurz danach nach Berlin gezogen und 23 Jahre später,
habe ich als Barkeeper angefangen zu arbeiten und habe
dann relativ schnell entdeckt dass mir das sehr gut gefällt und vor allem das Musikprogramm dazu selber zu gestalten in der damals Lychener Straße 60 das war ein ein Hausprojekt.
Anfang der 90er Jahre in Prenzlauer Berg und Berlin-Prenzlauer Berg und,
da habe ich dann zusammen mit mehreren Bekannten Freunden einen einen,
ein Kollektiv gehabt wo wir Veranstaltungen gemacht haben in einem Keller in diesem Haus Projekt und,
es war relativ schnell klar dass mir das wirklich sehr sehr gut gefällt und dann ging es halt,
auch schnell dass wir dann halt Alter für einen war Abend organisiert haben dort auch Veranstaltung durchgeführt haben am Anfang war es halt noch Rock'n'Roll Punk Konzerte,
aber wurden dann auch schnell Partys sowohl,
Rock n' Roll Musik Partys als auch dann später oder kurze Zeit später Techno und Trance.
Zeitmarke wann war da.
290 ca 92.
Was hat dir denn so gut gefallen daran an dieser Barkeeper Bildungssituation.
Na als erstes war ich immer schon so ein so eine Art Nachtmensch also es hat mir sehr sehr gut gefallen nach,
nicht so früh aufzustehen bzw möglich lange Nacht wach zu bleiben und dann
es hängt ein Anzugträger und wenn man sieht man kann die Leute unterhalten mit dem was man tut
da ich ihn nicht genau wusste was ich in welche berufliche oder was meine Perspektive ist ich hatte halt damals so
diverse Studiengänge die ich eigentlich alle abgebrochen habe wurde dann ziemlich schnell klar dass es
eventuell oder ziemlich sicher eine Richtung sein könnte die mir wirklich Spaß macht sowas zu organisieren und.
Leute zu bespaßen bzw das Rahmenprogramm dafür bereitzustellen dass Leute sich amüsieren können.
Sowohl beim Tanzen als auch beim Trinken als auch bei der Unterhaltung oder Unterhaltungen die geführt werden auch solchen Veranstaltung,
fand ich toll.
Ja ist denn so eine interessante Währung in der man da bezahlt wird ne also man abgesehen jetzt von Umsätzen und finanziellen Abrechnung,
habe ich ehrlich aber auch selber bei dem Veranstaltung ist so begleitet habe mal gemerkt so oder gibt's dann immer so Licht
Momente wo man einfach so eine Art Dankbarkeit zu zurückbekommt sich gar nicht so ohne weiteres greifen lässt sie irgendwie glücklich macht.
Na man könnte schon sagen dass es dann auch irgendwann,
wenn man drinnen ist so ein kleinen Suchtfaktor das ist entwickelt sich ein kleiner Suchtfaktor dass man will es immer wieder.
Wann will immer wieder dass die Leute oder dass man in glückliche Gesichter guckt weil man irgendwas gut gemacht hat und das war definitiv bei mir in der Fall dass ich das so das hat mich,
dann auch glücklich gemacht wenn ich gesehen habe dass den Leuten Veranstaltung gefallen hat die ich gerade für die organisiert habe oder wir für die organisiert haben es war der immer kollektive.
Was denkst du ist dir denn da gelungen dass das so war.
Ja diese einfach diese Gesichter zu sehen das.
Du eine Sache auf den Punkt bringen.
Die du dir vorher in deinem Kopf ausgedacht hast also wenn also jetzt dass ein bestimmter DJ die bestimmte Musik die du dir vorher überlegt hast,
dem Plattenspieler bringt oder auf dem Dancefloor bringt das ist halt einfach ein ein ein ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl mit den Leuten mit denen du feierst dass du das halt triffst,
für jeweils auf den Zeitgeist in dem sich gerade bewegst also war es am Anfang vielleicht noch mehr so die 80er Jahre Punk Underground independent Musik war es dann halt später,
die Techno Musik das ist.
Dass du halt den ja den den Punkt bei den Leuten trifft dass sie oder andersrum noch mal gesagt es gab ja.
Am Anfang der Techno Bewegung wir kamen alle aus dem Underground independent und dann wurdest Techno und die Leute kannten halt am Anfang nicht das.
Techno Gefühl und die da halt reinzubringen zu begleiten in diese neue komplett andere Welt war,
einfach ein schönes Gefühl das miterlebt zu haben bzw die Leute dahin zu entführen.
92 bei ungefähr so die Zeit wo es auch so richtig.
Wildwater der Techno so richtig nach Deutschland kam es mal schwierig sowas aufn einheitlichen Zeitpunkt zu machen also Ende der 80er jahre acid house ecetera schwappte das dann ja diese rebkultour auch nach Deutschland einerseits dann auch für die open air
Kultur teilweise von den ganzen Indian Reisenden nach Hamburg Loveparade startete 92.
Euer einiges in Wallung was was war denn dieses Techno Gefühl für dich was war denn der Unterschied ist das auf einmal so anders war als vorher.
Als allererstes mal war es glaube ich das allgemeine Lebensgefühl bei den Jugendlichen in Europa wir sind ja aufgewachsen mit dem Kalten Krieg,
und es war ständig eine Bedrohung die entweder real war oder heraufbeschworen wurde und.
Unsere ganze Schulzeit war wir standen eigentlich permanent Kurzform Atom.
Da war es gab's den Osten und es gab den Westen und mit dem Mauerfall war dieses ganze ist gab praktisch eine Explosion,
eine eine gefühlsexplosion in der Jugend in Europa es war auf einmal nicht mehr wichtig was in der Politik vorsichtigen sondern wurde sich,
ganz plötzlich darauf konzentriert möglichst viel Spaß in Muckis kurzer Zeit Vorhaben und daraus ist,
ja die ESET aus oder die Techno Bewegung entstanden und hatte halt ganz plötzlich ganz viel Einfluss auf uns,
das war halt nicht mehr dieses diese depressive independent Musik was heißt depressiv aber dies dieses Weltuntergangsszenario was vorher stur sondern.
The Cure und einfach so diese die Welt der Welt Schmerz.
Eurojet wischen und Weltschmerz sondern wurden die Grenzen vielen und zwar auf allen Ebenen und dann war.
Friedhof Freude Eierkuchen und Motte zu titrieren und dann war halt da diese Techno Musik und es wurde ausschweifend gefeiert.
Plötzlich überall es wurden ganzes gab dadurch dass die die Mauer fiel und Ostberlin.
Boot eine Menge an neuen aufregenden Locations die es zu bespielen galt also es gab.
Eine ganz neue Welt also wir ich komme auch aus dem Westen bin dann halt noch aus Berlin 91 oder 90 schon und es gab einfach einmal Freiräume die ist halt vorher nicht gab in Westberlin oder auch in Westdeutschland nicht,
gab,
große Fabrikhallen des gab kleine Wohnung ist wurde alles besetzt die halbe Stadt war besetzt und dementsprechend viele neue Möglichkeiten haben sich aufgetan.
Ja die auch vielfältig genutzt wurden ne.
Die sehr vielfältig genutzt worden ich kann mich erinnern wie redeten glaube ich damals von knapp 100 besetzten Häusern,
darüberhinaus gab's aber,
unzählige nicht bekannte ob sie auch besetzt Objekte in der ganzen Stadt also ich erinnere mich da gerne an den Hackeschen Markt bzw die Rosenthaler Straße und auch die Oranienburger Straße dabei
in jedem zweiten dritten Haus gab es irgendwo eine illegale Bar und.
Für jeden Wochentag des Tage.
Für jeden Wochentag es gab die montagsbar es gab die dienstags donnerstags Bar und am Wochenende wurden diese Bars dann halt auch zu großen tanzlocation.
Und unglaublich unglaublich viele neue Räume die plötzlich einfach da waren und nur darauf gewartet haben dass man dort irgendwas veranstaltet und genau zu dieser Zeit war ich halt dabei.
So ein bisschen die.
Urbane Perspektive also Berlin ist er dann insofern auch noch mal ein Sonderfall gewesen weil es eilig der einzige da nicht der einzige der ganz kalt ja im Prinzip auch für den ganzen Osten aber,
Berlin halt noch mal extremer natürlich aus dem Westen auf einmal auch soviel schon leicht rüber drücken konnte was nach diesem Freiräumen die ganze Zeit gesucht hat und das dann
weil sie mit einer kleinen Stadt Bahnfahrt erreichen konnte andererseits hat sich das ganze ja auch draußen,
gespielt aber diese Openair Kultur ich verrate dass du primären in Hamburg.
Hat sich dann ja erst so über die Zeit auch an den Berliner Raum heran geropp.
Naja so lange hat es dann auch nicht gedauert also es gab jetzt auf diesem.
Es gab die wofür expériences war Sonne Sonne transcor Veranstaltung glaube seit 91 oder 92.
92 und so relativ
kurz danach gabs auch im Umland von Berlin die ersten erst kleineren Open-Air-Veranstaltungen und dann entwickelte sich da so diese ganze Party Autobahn von Hamburg nach Berlin wo eigentlich.
Adidas adidas Autobahn aus.
Jeder Ausfahrt gab es dann plötzlich in den 97/98 an jeder Autobahnausfahrt gab's da irgendwo eine große große Open-Air-Veranstaltungen sowohl Techno als auch goa trance.
Was ist von dir nie an rede ich dann auch dabei ist ja auch das Fusion-Festival entstanden und ihr habt dann auch das ein oder andere beigetragen.
Wir haben da unter verschiedenen Namen verschiedenste Veranstaltungen macht jung wo auch zwischen Hamburg und Berlin oder östlich von Berlin irgendwelche Locations aufgetan wo ist dann möglich war
Veranstaltungen durchzuführen war relativ einfach zu der Zeit weil auch die.
Durchaus neugierig waren neue Einflüsse zu kriegen oder die wollten auf jeden Fall irgendwas ausprobieren
da hast du bei meinem Amt angerufen hast gesagt dass auch wir haben hier eine Wiese wir würden da gerne eine Musikveranstaltung durchführen
und es war deutlich einfacher als dass es heute ist da eine Genehmigung für zu kriegen sowas durchführen zu können weil die wussten halt auch erstmal nicht.
Was ist das.
Was ist das überhaupt wir können das gerne mal ausprobieren wir haben hier 40 Jahre lang Sozialismus gehabt da ging gar nichts und warum nicht,
und das war eine wirklich sehr sehr schöne Zeit muss ich sagen also sehr einfache Zeit um sowas durchzuführen war es.
Das war der legale Sektor dann gab es natürlich noch den illegalen Sektor das heißt du hast irgendwo eine Location aufgetan bis da einfach hingefahren hast da die PO aufgebaut hast ein Aggregat dahin gestellt hast und Lichter aufgebaut und hast,
Weihnachtszeit noch über eine mail legen Telefonhotline,
die Leute dazu aufgerufen an dem und dem Wochenende zu der und der Zeit da hinzukommen und mitzufeiern alles war ja noch eigentlich die Zeit vor Internet und Facebook.
Wir mussten ja noch ganz anders mobilisieren damals,
über kleine Flyer wo es dann eventuell direkt drauf stand oder aber sicherheitshalber erstmal nur eine Telefonnummer wo dein Anrufbeantworter war.
Wo denn gesagt wurde wohl.
Wo dann gesagt wurde wie man da hinkommt und.
Weil man selber noch nicht wusste oder.
Teilweise teilweise musste man selber nicht und man hatte natürlich die Optionen dann auf dem Anrufbeantworter zu sagen es ist funktioniert nicht weil irgendwas dazwischen gekommen ist war halt eine schöne Option so und,
ja weil es halt einfach auch teilweise nicht anders ging als so über einen Anrufbeantworter zu mobilisieren.
Gesagt also Flyer war das eine Ding das andere war halt ja so ein Telefon Hotline.
Heute auch ein bisschen darüber reden wie man.
Solche Partys gestalte meine deine Aufgabe in eurem Party Kollektiv die Pionen muss man ja auch noch mal sagen wann habt ihr angefangen als ich mit dem Namen.
Na der Name kam eigentlich später wir hatten eigentlich erstmal dieses Logo.
Die tanzenden Hirsch.
Nun Hirsche und
da wussten die Leute irgendwann nicht mehr genau also die sind da die haben uns aufgefordert das ganze noch mal zu benennen damit klar ist welche kruder eigentlich in dasteht und,
daraufhin haben wir halt uns in Hambühren ausgedacht bzw übernommen aus dem Wüstenplanet.
Na was war das denn noch.
Tagebuch Tage Tagelöhner Planeten gebundene Tagelöhner.
Und das passt ja eigentlich ganz gut weil Tagelöhner war ja im Prinzip genau das was wir gemacht haben wir haben das Anfang semiprofessionell betrieben und erst später.
Da wirklich eine regelmäßige Sache raus werden lassen mit der wir auch Geld verdienen konnten das war ja am Anfang erstmal gar nicht wichtig da war es wichtig dass eine Veranstaltungen
reine schwarze Null hat sage ich mal aber da war nicht unbedingt wichtig dass man damit Geld verdienen kann.
Bei mir auch noch am ausprobieren und am Suchen war was eigentlich funktioniert und hat sich ja auch am laufenden Meter geändert und.
Das mal so ist man muss ich dann immer wieder an neue Ereignisse und Rahmenbedingungen anpassen.
Und man braucht ein Team braucht ja andere Verbündete rasiere weiter haben im Kern erstmal zwei Leute und Markus.
Aber da stampft man ja mal nicht eben so eine Open-Air-Party zu zweit auf dem Boden.
Na ja wie gesagt die hatten halt dieses diese Lychener Straße oder lüg E60 genannt und da gab es halt auch ein paar ganz fitte Leute und mit denen wir das die ersten
Veranstaltung oder auch die ersten Jahre durchgeführt haben da waren paar Studenten aus der Kunsthochschule Weißensee da waren paar Leute die konnten so ein bisschen
Technik bzw Motoren und Motoren deswegen wichtig wegen Aggregaten und
hatten halt so eine halbwegs Elektriker Ausbildung und,
konnten uns halt beraten oder waren halt mit dabei dann halt einfach eine Struktur aufzubauen was braucht man eigentlich für einen open air
also sprich Aggregate Stromkabel ein bisschen Licht und alles nicht auf eine Faser hauen und also also
diese Beratung und wir waren eine kleine Gruppe also vielleicht so 67 Leute am Anfang und das hat sich dann.
Über die Jahre auf eine sehr sehr große und stabile Bruin aus entwickelt,
so aber die ersten Leute mit denen wir es gemacht haben und teilweise heute immer noch machen nach 25-30 Jahren kommen alle aus der Küche 60 noch.
So und dann sind halt jetzt Zimmerleute dazugekommen und Gastro Spezialisten und so weiter und sofort aber,
ja die ersten waren alle aus diesen einen Quatsch.
Wie hält man so eine Gruppe zusammen woran merkt man dass man den richtigen,
Leuten unterwegs sein also ich habe so auch die Beobachtung gemacht so oft Cups Partys die auch ein bisschen an sich selbst und nicht selten auch am,
Lego einzelner gescheitert sind sie vielleicht selbst übernommen haben oder generell einfach nur zu wichtig,
die leicht merken,
von zum Geltungsbedürfnis auch manchmal geleitet waren und sich dabei selbst überschätzt haben und nicht den richtigen modus gefunden haben.
So ich würde mich würde mal sagen dass das allererste um dich digste ist Vertrauen Vertrauen in die Stärken der anderen Leute mit denen du das zusammen machst und Ehrlichkeit,
also wenn du Geld verdienst mit sowas dann ist es halten,
einfach nur fair das Geld halt auch unter die Leute zu verteilen die damit gearbeitet haben und ich glaube da sind im Laufe der Jahre sehr viele Gruß auch dran gescheitert dass sobald Geld ins Spiel kam
das ist halt vielleicht nicht ehrlich aufgeteilt wurde oder die Leute die es organisiert haben sich zuviel Geld in die Tasche gesteckt haben und andere Leute raus gedrängt wurden ausdehnen
aus dem kollektiven und das war von Anfang an ganz ganz wichtiger Punkt bei uns dass wir halt sagen sobald Geld reinkommt fallen wie die Leute auch
oder bezahlen sie sowieso und müssen das Geld was wir den Leuten Zahlen halt auch erwirtschaften und,
das war nicht bei allen.
Da hieß es halt wenn die Party gut läuft dann kriegen paar Leute Geld und viele andere Leute die mitgeholfen haben kriegen kein Geld das war bei uns von Anfang an so dass wir gesagt haben okay das ist das was Du dafür kriegst,
wenn wir diese Veranstaltung gemacht haben sind da natürlich auch ein paar mal böse abgestürzt weil wir,
viel Geld versprochen hatten oder zuviel in zuviel ins Risiko gegangen sind und
nachher hat es geregnet oder irgendwie sind trotzdem nicht genug Leute gekommen und dann hattest du halt auch einmal ein ganz ganz dickes - aber wir haben halt trotzdem zu erwärmen zugesehen dass wir die Leute
zahlen ganz egal wie es gelaufen ist und das haben nicht alle gemacht.
Aber es ist ja nicht nur stimmt ja zu dass das an der Stelle war das immer so ein kritischer Faktor ist schon mal wichtig ist.
Das auf die falsch mal vom Tisch zu haben,
was ist ja auch nicht alles also ist ja auch nicht so dass man die Leistung die viele Leute da erbringen auch so ohne weiteres in Anführungsstrichen nur,
mit Geld abgleichen kann man sich anschaut was da teilweise Leistungen kreative Leistung oder auch einfach handwerklicher Kraftleistung.
Nein dich also wie ist es wir machen das alle nicht weil wir da unheimlich viel Geld mitverdienen das ist das ist nicht das was ich sagen wollte es ist du musst da ganz viel Spaß mitbringen wenn du sowas machen willst,
du brauchst da ganz viel Enthusiasmus weil es ist teilweise wirklich harter Job der da gemacht wird und es geht da.
Aufbauten die entweder über mehrere Tage gehen oder aber ganz schnell in einer Nacht erledigt werden müssen und da brauchst du halt definitiv motivierte Mitarbeiter
die dahinterstehen eine Veranstaltung zu machen die also auch selber den Spaß mitbringen sowas durchzuführen.
Wie hält man diese Motivation aufrecht oder wie muss man die schaffen oder muss man sich nur aufrecht halten.
Die Motivation muss natürlich von allen mitgebracht werden du kannst nicht zu jemandem hingehen und sagen hier ist jetzt ganz geil was wir machen und jetzt wirst du hier auch Partyveranstalter oder jetzt musst du mit in dieses Kollektivs ohne
Leute mit denen du das machst bring das eigentlich schon mit bloßem musst du die Motivation dann irgendwo aufhalten.
Musst eine gute Veranstaltung machen und somit die Leute die dabei sind bei der Stange halten und ja das ist so eine vielleicht auch eine kleine Kunst sowas zu tun.
Wie ganz genau das funktioniert.
Das auch noch nicht verstand.
Habe ja auch noch nicht verstanden
es funktioniert ganz gut bei uns muss ich sagen also wir arbeiten wirklich viele viele Jahre du weißt es auch mit den mit den gleichen Leuten zusammen
ohne dass sie es ist nicht so dass die jetzt alle in Party Business arbeiten viele von denen mit denen wir heute noch Sachen machen haben ganz andere Jobs inzwischen
komm dann halt wieder zusammen um eine Veranstaltung durchzuführen.
Ist ja auch logisch also nicht jeder der von Anfang an dabei ist konnte damit so viel Geld verdienen dass er sein Leben damit finanzieren kann aber die haben halt immer noch so viel Spaß daran.
Dass sie heute wenn wir rufen Sie alle immer noch kommen.
Muss man vielleicht mal erklären also ihr habt ja in den ersten Jahren neben dieser Bar dann diverse Partys pro Jahr gemacht was in der Größenordnung von so 67.
Ja teilweise auch mehr teilweise waren es auch deutlich mehr in 23 45 Jahren dass wir mindestens einmal im Monat noch anstaltungen gemacht haben oder machen mussten.
Warte Wattierung.
Oben.
Ja und das hat sich dann halt irgendwann ein wenig eingedampft.
Reduziert dadurch dass wir halt mehrere Kneipen in Berlin eröffnet haben mussten wir dann halt nicht mehr so viele Veranstaltungen machen sondern haben oder Hamm diese Veranstaltung dann in die Bars verlegt so zu also.
Nicht im Techno Bereich aber wir haben dann halt andere Veranstaltung in den Bars durchgeführt und hatten auch nicht mehr die Kapazitäten jeden Monat noch Veranstaltungen im im Techno Bereich zu machen dazu kommt aber auch,
es gab die Locations dann irgendwann auch einfach nicht mehr um das überhaupt durchführen zu können.
Wir kommen jetzt in die 2000er Jahre schon es wurde dann deutlich schwieriger an an irgendwelche Fabrikhallen oder Keller ranzukommen was Mitte der 90er überhaupt kein Problem war.
Entwickelte sich dann zu einem riesen Aufwand sowohl.
Genehmigungs technisch als auch Verfügbarkeit Verfügbarkeit von diesem location zur einfach nicht mehr da.
Ja die Stadt wurde voller viele Gebäude wurden saniert.
Und es war ein die Verdrängung in die Außenbezirke oder Gentrifizierung genannt,
setzte dann halt irgendwann ein.
Hattest du in den 90ern hat mir eben schon gesagt in Mitte Oranienstraße runyan burgerstraße Hackescher Markt war da noch alles voll mit illegalen Clubs und Locations wo man was machen konnte.
Wurde es plötzlich Rummelsburg oder Außenbezirke außerhalb des S-Bahn rings.
Wichtiger. War glaube ich auch dass Anwohner die in den 90er Jahren noch mitgezogen haben auch mangels Telefon die Polizei nicht rufen konnte.
Plötzlich.
Plötzlich in der Lage waren durch Mobilfunk oder Festnetz die Polizei zu alarmieren und dann tauchten da Einsatzkräfte auf die sich erstmal gefragt haben was macht ihr denn hier bitteschön.
Und das war in den 90ern halt alles deutlich einfacher so.
Wo bin ich hier jetzt ich sehe hier so ein Bild von der Congresshalle Halle am Alexanderplatz da haben wir ja auch mal eine große Silvesterparty gemacht.
Das war halt einfach möglich das kann man sich heute alles gar nicht mehr vorstellen oder wir hatten mal das Palais Dernburg Unter den Linden zur Silvester 2004 Act neben der russischen Botschaft.
Da
Vorstellbar heutzutage.
Völlig unvorstellbar heutzutage da kam die Polizei auch noch fragte was macht ihr denn hier und gesagt mehrere offizielle Begleitprogramm zu Silvester 2000 und am Brandenburger Tor.
Und also ist es geht heute einfach nicht mehr und ja traumhafte Zeiten.
Ja aber ihr habt dann auch euer Openair Programm deutlich reduziert was übrig geblieben ist ist die Traditionsveranstaltung kann man das glaube ich mittlerweile nennen die nation of Gondwana wird in diesem Jahr,
25 mal begangen das ist ja schon eine Leistung hat meintest ja vorhin so die Leute,
kommen dann halt teilweise nur noch zu dieser zu einer Veranstaltung das ist dann natürlich aus deiner Perspektive diese.
Dass ich viele so alte Gesichter alte wo klar ist so eigentlich haben die so mit parties
nicht viel zu tun in ihrem Leben aber da will man schon dabei sein also merkt man das dann auch auf einer organisatorischen Ebene eine Bindung zu so ein Event
geschaffen wurde die im Jenseits von finanzieller Vergütung ist da mag immer so ein bisschen persönlicher Hang dazu und Tradition sein aber ich denke spielt jetzt auch noch mal so in diese Frage mit wie baut man in dieses Vertrauen auf,
wird eigentlich auch in gewisser Hinsicht das Vertrauen auch immer so ein bisschen zurückgezahlt weil die Leute sagen naja also
ohne kann ich jetzt auch nicht und obwohl es alles gar nicht mein Film ist mich trotzdem in der Lage ja auch jederzeit immer wieder meine Rolle zu finden so,
als patiszon Urlaub Arbeit.
Es ist fast wie so ein Arbeitsurlaub also du du du siehst Leute dort die auch frühzeitig anreisen die gar nichts mehr mit,
Party zu tun haben die wirklich nur noch einmal im Jahr auf die auf die nation of Gondwana kommen vielleicht noch auf die Fusion gehen und weil das ist der gleiche Dunstkreis an Menschen aber sonst.
Eigentlich.
Familien haben reguläre Jobs haben irgendwo und gar nicht mehr in diesem ganzen Feier Kontext unterwegs sind und,
ja das ist eigentlich schöne das ist so eine Art Klassentreffen oder Familientreffen einmal im Jahr man freut sich man weiß
es kommen ganz viele Leute mit denen man seine Jugend verbracht hat oder seinen seinen Erwachsenwerden verbracht hat und die trifft man halt und.
Aus ganz Deutschland die kommen halt zu diesen Events und haben den Spaß ihres Lebens noch einmal im Jahr.
Trotzdem habe ich nicht so den Eindruck dass es sich in so eine alte Leute Veranstaltungen.
Es ist keine alte Leute Veranstaltungen sind ja auch alle Junggebliebenen guck uns an.
Aber ist jetzt auch nicht so das jetzt überhaupt keine jüngeren Generation mit am Spaß teilhaben würden also da ist sozusagen die Nachfrage ist noch da.
Die Nachfrage ist auf jeden Fall da und es gibt ja auch in denen die die Entwicklung als die letzten Jahre sind die Open Airs aus dem Boden geschossen,
wissen jetzt die letzten zwei Jahre haben wieder ein paar die die die Segel gestrichen aus welchen Gründen auch immer diverse Gründe aber die Nachfrage nach,
Kulturveranstaltungen auf dem Land ist riesig,
so vielleicht auch dadurch bedingt dass in der Stadt halt einfach nichts mehr geht außer den regulären Clubs aber du findest kaum noch auf locations.
Du hier bespielen kannst ich habe da neulich mal so eine Umfrage so eine so eine Umfrage in so einem Forum gehabt da waren dann zwei of locations,
in Lichterfelde das ist also ein Stadtteil im Süden von Berlin.
Wo du vor 10-15 Jahren im Traum nicht dran gedacht hättest dass da mal irgendwas gehen könnte oder würde und der Rest ist ja,
den gibt es einfach nicht mehr in Berlin Innenstadt und das ist und es ist in Hamburg ähnlich also oder in in in allen größeren deutschen Städten wo.
Vor vielen Jahren halt irgendwas in der Innenstadt organisiert wurde wird es gibt halt einfach diese Verdrängung nach außen und deswegen sind Open Airs auch heute gerade ganz aktuell immer noch.
Schöner Freiraum um sich selbst oder wir um sich selbst zu verwirklichen als Party.
Jetzt mal so ein bisschen.
Mal ganz unabhängig davon wie wie wie wie schwierig das jetzt ist und wie sehr sich die Rahmenbedingungen erinnert habe ich vergiss mal nicht sagen es ist total unmöglich ja vielleicht muss man sich in gewisser Hinsicht auch auf,
orte mal berufen die man ebenso derzeit noch nicht auf den Zeiger hatte und letztenendes sehe ich auch nicht unbedingt jetzt als ein großes,
Problem an wenn jetzt am Rand von Berlin die Orte auf einmal gefunden werden weil san2 Zufall,
immer noch erreichbar und wenn sie in gewisser Hinsicht auch noch den selben Anforderungen genügen.
Na dann dann ist es halt so dann kommen die Leute ja dann da auch hin dass ich mich erinnere mich auch daran das irgendwie wirklich
der tiefsten Botanik irgendwo in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Schleswig-Holstein wo es einfach schwierig war der überhaupt erstmal physisch hinzukaufen Wege gefunden haben und wie kilometerweit durch
dunkle Wälder und was nicht alles damit sich dann am Ende gelohnt hat war ja auch da so ein bisschen
der Weg das Ziel war unser Belohnung suspect das wird ne Stunden hatten im Nichts unterwegs war es
keinen Google Maps gab keine Navigation gab nur um paar Zettel oder noch schlimmer so so Schnitzeljagd
mäßig das um du sang diese Party vollständig vor wem auch immer zu verstecken alle paar Kilometer mal wieder ein Hinweisschild oder Westphal vielleicht noch Rätsel aufgestellt wurden wurden Chance Account reinzukommen also gibt ja diese Orte
Frage ist was kannst du denn so aus seiner Erfahrung sagen wie sonst Gauting funktionieren,
sollte oder wie hat es bei dir funktioniert aber jetzt mal die höhere Verfügbarkeit von von von Möglichkeiten mal rausrechnen,
drauf muss man überhaupt.
Wenn wir jetzt mal kurz bei den Open Airs bleiben also ich hatte mir damals parat Karten besorgt.
Und anhand dieser fahrradkonvoi Fahrradkarten sind da ist alles sehr detailgenau eingezeichnet und ich bin anhand dieser Fahrradkarten mit dem Auto dann rund um den Berliner Ring gefahren weil es sind ja
wie du jetzt schon sagtest was willst du mit dabei Veranstaltungen Oderbruch erstmal du kuckst natürlich erstmal wo.
Ist die Erreichbarkeit oder wo wo könnte man das am besten durchführen also habe ich Fahrradkarten besorgt und bin an dieser Fahrradkarten die Locations abgefahren.
Möglichst an einem See oder in einem Gewässer lagen und eine große Waldlichtung Booten oder eine große Wiese booten.
Was war denn jetzt an den Fahrradkarten anders als an anderen.
Na der Maßstab weil du dich mit dem Fahrrad halt deutlich langsamer bewegst hast du da halt einen anderen Maßstab als auf einer autokarte.
Auf der autokarte ist halt einfach sind die Autobahnen eingezeichnet auf einer Fahrradkarte sind Wälder und Wiesen eingezeichnet.
Und auch mehr Gebäude.
Mehr Gebäude mehr einfach mehr Details der Maßstab ist halt ein einfach ein anderer als und anhand dieser Fahrradkarten habe ich dann halt.
Diese Lichtung oder ja diese wiesen versucht zu finden und.
Musste du konntest das nur überprüfen indem du hinfährst und dann die Gegebenheiten vor Ort dann wirklich checkst Zufahrtswege.
Wie sieht das Gebäude was du auf dieser Karte gesehen hast in real aus was sind da für Nachbarn wie kannst du die Situation einschätzen ist die Wiese.
Eine trockene Wiese oder liegt die so tief dass es sich um einen kleinen Sumpf handelt und solche Details waren halt einfach wichtig heutzutage setzte sich Google an an Google,
Earth Google Maps und fliegst halt praktisch die Gelände ab das war halt damals überhaupt nicht möglich.
Also musstest du konntest du das nur checken indem du vor Ort ganz konkret eine geländebegehung machst.
Ja aber auch sein jetzt Google Earth verwendet springt an mehr vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt immer alles sofort.
Das stimmt aber du kannst du kannst da irgendwie kannst halt einfach rein fliegen.
Ja klar aber die Frage ist worauf achtet man dann was überprüft man.
Man überprüft das möglichst eine Barriere musst halt mal davon ausgehen du hast eine Scheibe Richtung eine Richtung in die Du schreien möchtest wenn du jetzt mal von einer Tanzfläche auf gehst.
Und günstigstenfalls ist.
Zwischen der payaso zwischen den Boxen den die du aufbaust und dann kommt die Tanzfläche und hinter der Tanzfläche sollte nach Möglichkeit irgendwo im Wald kommen.
Indem der Sound weil dann verschwinden kann genau und das sind halt so wichtige Parameter um sowas überhaupt wenn wenn du keinen Wald zwischen.
Pierre und im nächsten Dorf hast.
Hast du wahrscheinlich auch nicht so große Chance in diese Veranstaltungen über einen längeren Zeitraum durchzuführen sondern da kannst du ganz ganz schnell damit rechnen dass irgendwer kommt und.
Wie viel Kilometer Wald werden da ganz angemessen abgesehen von so viel wie.
Namen paar 100m würde ich sagen sind schon sind schon tolle Sachen was wir früher auch hatten waren,
sandkuhlen geht heute auch nicht mehr aber wir haben da halt auch so ein paar sandkuhlen gefunden gehabt ideal stellst nur Pierre rein und.
Hört dich für Stunden vermutlich keiner und findet dich vermutlich vier Stunden auch kein.
Aber das wird nicht so genau orten kann.
Weil man es nicht orten kann wo das überhaupt herkommt da geht der Sound in die Wand und von der Wand geht's nach oben und das musst du erstmal,
das musst du erstmal geordnet.
Fast unmöglich so ich kann dich an eine Veranstaltung erinnern da kam die Polizei dann nach Stunden
nach Stunden und sie sagten auf die haben euch Stunden gesucht und wir wussten nicht wo wir euch wo wir euch finden könnt die waren sehr freundlich die haben dann auch gesagt mach mal weiter wir wollten einfach nur mal wissen um was es sich hier handelt,
und räumt auf wenn Ihr fertig seid und wir kontrollieren das dann morgen und ja wann wäre sehr freundlich zu uns.
Aber das sind halt so so und wie gesagt wenn wenn günstigstenfalls wenn du da noch einen kleinen See hast um dich zwischendurch auch mal abzukühlen dann ist es toll.
Da gibt ja das Berliner Umland eine Menge her.
Da gibt es Berliner Umland ne Menge her heute brauchst du halt den Genehmigung für sowas ging das früher halt noch so,
geht es heute nicht mehr und es sind halt jetzt auch ganz viele Gebiete Umweltschutz Gebiete geworden hat er früher vielleicht auch nicht so unbedingt immer jemand dran gedacht und ja es ist alles nicht mehr so einfach.
Meine Genehmigung braucht,
wie kriegt man die also sag mal mal wir haben jetzt so eine passende Location gefunden wie sollte man jetzt rangehen
um sowas dann auch genehmigt zu bekommen ist hatte man hat jetzt wirklich vor mal die Grenzen nicht genehmigungsfähige Aktivitäten auszuloten
man kann ja auch versuchen das trade ranzugehen mit wem sollte man da zuerst bei dir was die Nachbarn,
erwähnt wenn man da ist die die erste Adresse.
Nee die Nachbarn sind mit Sicherheit nicht die erste Adresse die erste Adresse wäre jetzt mal das Ordnungsamt ich muss dazu sagen ich bin nicht bei uns der Genehmigung sexperte das macht der Markus.
Ja ja.
Aber sowas ich halt das erste ant erster Ansprechpartner ist immer das Ordnungsamt wenn das Ordnungsamt,
so und hat's da hattest du früher
eigentlich nur das Ordnungsamt und dann noch das Gewerbeamt als Ansprechpartner ist es inzwischen die halbe Verwaltung die dahinter steht kommt dann so ein bisschen auf die Größe an das Bauamt ist entscheiden natürlich redet man mit dem Bürgermeister.
Gewerbeamt an.
Du schutzbehörde.
Naturschutzbehörde untere Naturschutz dann versucht man Kontakt von Förster aufzubauen weil wenn der Förster keinen Bock hat ist auch immer schwierig sowas machen.
Alles schon erlebt da hat das Amt fand es alles ganz toll und dann kam auf einmal der Förster Endspiel der gesagt hat aber doch bitte nicht in meinem Wald.
So und dann okay wir machen es einmal wir sind nächstes Jahr wieder woanders so also das,
hast du alles monatelang vorbereitet dann kriegt der Förster Wind von der Sache und sagte aber näheres machen jetzt einmal und nie wieder,
so und nee aber du musst die alle Behörden mit einziehen einbeziehen heutzutage das ist geht gar nicht ohne und es ist gerade nach Duisburg.
Ist dir.
Die wollen sich alle abgesichert haben dass sie da bloß nichts Falsches machen und du musst da conceptum conceptum concepto also Sicherheitskonzepte und was weiß ich nicht was alles auf dem Tisch legen das war,
in den Anfangszeiten so ein bisschen anders hatte ich ja gerade schon gesagt da war es eigentlich das Ordnungsamt und das Gewerbeamt und das reichte dann in der Regel und wenn dann der Bürgermeister noch auf deiner Seite war dann konnte.
Paul Feldmann Ausflug gerade in die aktuelle Diskussion machen ja.
Haben heute in 22 Mai 2019 befinden uns noch mitten im wilden hin und her den Auseinandersetzung um das Fusion-Festival
Veranstaltung die etwa zeitgleich mit eurer Veranstaltungen.
Bisschen später.
Bisschen später die nach euch kahn dann geht's los hier.
Also die erste nation of Gondwana war 95 ich glaube die erste Fusion war 1997 man muss aber auch dazu sagen wir kommen,
wir haben die ersten Jahre sehr sehr eng zusammengearbeitet mit der schuh Synchro also wir kennen uns sehr sehr gut wir haben uns da.
Immer und überall unterstützt wo es ging.
Und es gab viel sehr viel Überschneidung von daher ist die Nation war halt jetzt einfach 2 Jahre vorher das heißt nicht,
wie viel sind gut ist es ja damals noch useit nicht zur gleichen Zeit auch schon was gemacht hat also es gab eine parallele Entwicklung zwischen in Hamburg und in Berlin also es gab da sowohl regen Austausch als Musiker anging als auch was was
die Gruß anging also das war eigentlich ein großes Konglomerat an Party wie liegen die
sowohl in Hamburg als auch im Berliner Umfeld zur gleichen Zeit angefangen hat sowas zu organisieren so und,
ja
Die Duschen hat er dann natürlich den Sonderstatus weil sie dieses wunderbare Gelände gefunden haben in der Nähe
ehemaliger russischer
Militärflughafen mit vielen Hangars und einigen Gebäuden viel Platz Platz daneben
kann sehe aber den haben sie sich dann später noch dazu gebaut man gönnt sich ja sonst nichts
und ja die Veranstaltung ist daneben unter diesen Bedingungen auch ziemlich stark gewachsen weil sie in diesen Raum hatte und in gewisser Hinsicht auch zu den Zuspruch des Umlandes.
Ja es war halt.
Der Vorteil die haben das Gelände relativ schnell gekauft und das hieß sie konnten dass sie konnte halt praktisch Jahr für Jahr auf das auf dem aufbauen was sie,
das Jahr vorher schon hatten also mussten nicht großartig wie alle anderen immer wieder abbauen und das nächste Jahr wieder aufbauen sondern die konnten halt.
Ihre Strukturen wachsen lassen was definitiv ein Vorteil war und die hatten halt die Hangars und hatten halt die Lagerkapazitäten und haben dann wirklich wirklich schöne Sache raus gemacht im Laufe der letzten 20 Jahren.
Das ist ein riesiger alternativer Freizeitpark kann man fast sagen also es ist wirklich so ein Wunderwelt des Wahnsinns,
die dich davor findet und Deutsch stream viele Gruppen die sich dort austoben also jetzt Rahmen der.
Diskussion um das neue Sicherheitskonzept was gefordert wird kam so zu Sprache das ungefähr 200 Gruppen mehr oder weniger unabhängig,
ja dieser Veranstaltung beitragen ist das bei euch auch so ein bisschen also ich meinte dieses werden vorhin darüber gesprochen.
Man braucht Vertrauen in die Leute das ist klar so und sind ein Spiel mit mit mit mit Zusagen mit Motivation mit mit mit guter Stimmung und Gewissen sie auch mit Verlässlichkeit.
Wenn so eine Veranstaltung so groß wird dann kann man ja auch unmöglich,
noch alles im Blick haben sonst was es ist unmöglich aus einer Zentralperspektive da so ein Micromanagement zu betreiben weil man muss ja dann auch irgendwann mal loslassen und sagen,
ja habt ihr das Wäldchen macht mal so ihr nimmt den Hangar macht was draus das scheint ja ganz gut funktioniert zu haben.
Das scheint da sehr gut funktioniert zwar mit meinem ich bin nicht mehr ganz so,
wie ich früher mal gewesen bin aber das was ich jetzt immer noch mit kriege über die vielen gemeinsamen Bekannten bzw auch über die Crew selbst
läuft halt genauso dass es da werden halt die Floors verteilt einen Gruß aus ganz Deutschland die das dann.
Spielen können also das welchen spiel mal den sebis spiel mal den Hangar und der wird sich halt,
zu einem Plenum und da wird das halt besprochen und vergeben und die groß können da halt ihren eigenen space kreieren verwalten und bespielen so und das ist.
Navi vorne ganz ganz wunderbare Sache was da stattfindet mit ja wie du es eben auch schon sagtest mit annähernd 200 verschiedenen Gruß aus,
vermutlich inzwischen ganz Europa und.
C1000 Deutsche sollen das allein schon sein von den 70000.
Ich kann mir das gut vorstellen mit Freunden und Freundesfreunde die bauen ja über über Wochen auf das ist ja nicht so dass weil das ist halt wieder der Vorteil das Gelände gehört den spricht musst halt erstmal keine Miete bezahlen und hast halt,
einfach über Wochen Zeit ganz.
Über Monate du hast einen praktisch das ganze Jahr Zeit ja deinen deinen deinen space zu kreieren und.
Dazu arbeiten ohne ja Geld dafür bezahlen zu müssen dass du da bist wie das überall anders der Fall wäre,
und du musst da auch jetzt niemand großartig von überzeugen dass du da arbeiten kannst so meint das ist die ganze Struktur.
Bietet das einfach du hast da diverse Küchen wo du dich selbst versorgen kannst und hast du einen einen einfachen eine riesen Gelände wo du dich hinstellen kannst mit
und kannst da halt mit deiner Crew deine dein Bereich ausbauen.
Und das Jahr für Jahr und Monat oder man wird ja das eigentlich wirklich ja für ja tolle Sachen.
Als Gipser neuen Polizeipräsidenten der möchte jetzt gerne,
Änderung herbeiführen kann mit der Forderung auf man es wäre doch mal ganz toll wenn diese Fahrrad.
Von der Polizei gestreift wird wie das so schön heißt wollen da irgendwie mit 1000 Polizisten über diese Veranstaltung schleichen um irgendwas zu verhindern was da.
Noch nie stattgefunden hat.
Noch nicht stattgefunden hat.
Ja ist absurd es ist wirklich absurd ich meine nein ein Festival was weiter 21 Jahren besteht und wo ist.
Einfach keine besonderen schwerwiegenden Vorkommnisse gegeben hat in all den Jahren den,
wird jetzt einen ein neues Sicherheitskonzept verordnet was vielleicht überhaupt gar nicht,
ja sind was definitiv nicht gewollt ist und was vielleicht auch gar nicht vonnöten ist und das was jetzt gerade in der Presse war oder ist
ganz aktuell also wenn ich lese das da ist schon Wasserwerfer angefordert werden und Räumpanzer und das für Spezialeinheiten angefordert wurden oder werden die Leute in Gold Erde gegen Gorleben und den von den Gleisen geschnitten haben.
Jesus und der Technik und lösen.
Technik und lösen da fragt man sich was.
Haben die davor also wieso wird eine eine Kulturveranstaltung die.
20 Jahren überaus erfolgreich und friedlich existiert warum,
muss da jetzt unbedingt ein neues polizeikonzept angesetzt werden um Situationen zu schaffen.
Die vorher überhaupt gar nicht existiert haben also nichts gegen gegen Polizeikontrollen im Vorfeld und bei der Abfahrt im Straßenverkehr.
Aber.
Was also ich verstehe nicht ganz wo das hinführen soll jetzt diesen kulturellen Freiraum dermaßen einzuengen und mit 100 schaften behelmt 100 schafften zu bestreifen ich meine wir.
Ja das ist es wird eine eine funktionierende Struktur.
Kulturveranstaltungen mutwillig zerstört also mehr kann ich mir darunter gerade nicht erklären und vorstellen was ziel des Ganzen sein soll.
Wann ist es gab drei oder vier anzeigen pro Jahr bei der Polizei Diebstahlsanzeige no Kate es passiert auf jedem Festival
das irgendwie auf das mal sein sollen Handy geklaut wird oder sein irgendwas aus dem Zelt gestohlen wird das kann man bei der Größe auch gar nicht verhindern
aber dass das jetzt ran gezogen wird um eine,
24-Stunden Bestreifung von the Hampton Hundertschaften durchzuführen ist einfach eine ganz abstruse Vorstellung.
David können wir natürlich lange rum spekulieren was jetzt hier die eigentliche Motivation dahinter zu sein scheint also es ist sicherlich nicht gibt sicherlich keinen konkreten Anlass.
Den hat diese Veranstaltung niemals geliefert.
Wir leben ja schon seit einigen Jahren so die Erneuerung von Polizeigesetz in verschiedenen Bundesländern ist das jetzt schon durchgekommen Jürgens in Niedersachsen,
oh ja aber generell der Polizei mehr Eingriffsmöglichkeiten gegeben werden.
Stendal Tatbestände geschaffen werden wo solange noch gar nichts passiert ist waren wo einfach nur vorgefahren,
gewarnt werden macht auch ein bisschen den Eindruck als ob einfach der Freiraum selbst als Bedrohung angesehen wird das sozusagen Leute die sich,
frei fühlen wollen so Tank schon als als Drohung eines.
Irgendwie gedachten systems.
Das macht genau den Eindruck also mein wir haben es jetzt auch nicht nur in der Kultur,
Volks und bisschen die Fußballwelt da haben wir ja ähnliche Ansätze gerade das sehr viel.
Freiheit die es vorher gab jetzt durch die neuen Polizeigesetze eingeschränkt werden und das dehnt sich halt jetzt vom Fußball auf die Feierkultur bzw auf Kulturveranstaltungen aus und.
Schwierig dafür uns den Sinn zu erkennen.
Aber ich fürchte irgendwelche Leute werden sich da was bei denken und das ist für.
Vielleicht freiheitsliebenden nicht unbedingt zum Vorteil gereicht.
Also das wird massiv eingeschränkt aber das ist eine Entwicklung die gibt's ja eigentlich schon seit vielen vielen Jahren das ist ja ist ja jetzt nichts Neues nur.
Mit der Juden Diskussionen geht es jetzt in eine breite Öffentlichkeit hinein sodass es.
Ja da wird halt gerade.
Jamso wird eigentlich Bad versucht massiv einzuschränken und es gibt da ein breites Bündnis von Leuten die es jetzt dagegen wehren und das ist auch gut so.
Berlin hat sich ja die ganze Partykultur schon vor einigen Jahren so ein paar Strukturen geschaffen mir fällt dir so klappt komischen die so ein bisschen so ein
Verbund von Club Betreibern in Berlin und Umland Versicherung Donauwelle alles noch mit dazu gehört gegründet hat da hast du ja auch so deine Ohren mit drin.
Da habe ich so ein bisschen mein Ohr mit drin also ich bin nicht so der Riesen Verwaltungs Mensch muss ich gestehen aber natürlich verfolge ich das alles
ne das ist sehr sehr gut sich gemeinsam gegen irgendwas zu werden oder für irgendwas Einzug einzusetzen das ist,
Beigel GEMA Tarifen los und es geht über Genehmigungsverfahren und was was Lärmschutz
was immer weiter eingeengt wird und sich da,
einen Austausch zu finden und vielleicht auch Experten daran zu lassen die man gemeinsam finanziert,
ist durchaus sehr sinnvoll und die clubcommission oder clubkommission gibt's jetzt auch seit 15 Jahren glaube ich inzwischen und,
gibt auch in Hamburg da heißt es ein bisschen anders in Köln und wird ein Netzwerk organisiert was für ganz Deutschland greift und es gibt regelmäßigen Austausch.
Unterm ja das Bild versucht gemeinsam Ziele zu erreichen bzw neue Gesetzesvorlagen abzuwenden was z.b. Lärmschutz angeht.
Unter.
Ja Freiräume halt.
Freiräume erhalten ja,
bzw des schaffen ist halt genau das Problem das ist halt schwierig als es wird immer schwieriger Freiräume oder neue Freiräume zu kriegen aber das was wir haben zu erhalten wär ja schon mal der erste.
Wie erklärst du denn dann dass wir jetzt eine.
Also 90er Jahre werden für diese Aufbruch Situation gesprochen und diesem diesem gilt in dieser gelebten freier da haben ja nicht wenig Leute dran teilgenommen.
Also wenn man sich die die Menge an Leuten die eigentlich diese ganze Zeit begleitet hat mal versucht grob zu überschlagen
Shops überall Loveparade platzt aus allen Nähten war beileibe nicht die einzige Veranstaltung Millionen an an Leuten die eigentlich,
das intensiv durchgeatmet haben das ganze ist jetzt schon 20 Uhr,
darf 30 Jahre fast ja dass das,
wie laut ist ja jetzt eigentlich alle im wirk wegen alter 40-50 bestimmen in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch sozialen den auf den politisch aktiven Teil dieser Gesellschaft.
Wieso was denkst du hat dazu geführt dass das dass diese Freiheit an der Stelle
als nicht ausreichend erhaltenswert angesehen wird oder haben wir jetzt nur das Gefühl dass du dieses Übermaß an Freiheit etwas eingeschränkt wird und dass das dann schon wieder zu weit geht müsste sich doch jetzt,
eigentlich so ein bisschen auch mal ein anderer Blick durchsetzen lassen.
Schwierig schwierige schwieriges Feld also ich glaube.
Das hat sich verschoben also hatten wir vor 20 Jahren hat niemand über Religionen diskutiert und es verschiebt sich jetzt gerade in in ein einen eine Einrichtung das,
ist wieder Anfeindungen unter den verschiedenen Religionen auf dieser Welt.
So und das ich glaube das ist ein ganz ganz großer Grund dafür dass da werden neue Sicherheitsstandards kreiert die vielleicht überhaupt nicht notwendig wären.
Aber es werden neue Gefahren heraufbeschworen angeblich gibt es eine neue Bedrohung vielleicht war
einigen Menschen das einfach zu viel Freiheit wir hatten ja ganz am Anfang mal gesagt
wir kommen aus den 80ern da war der Atomkrieg Szenario was immer,
vor uns geschwebt hat und dieser Atomkrieg oder diese Diskussion gibt es seit damals nicht mehr aber vielleicht braucht es,
oder wollen einige Kräfte in dieser Gesellschaft neue Gefahren heraufbeschwören um.
Kontrolle zu bewahren über über das System als mein spielt natürlich auch.
Das Internet eine gewisse Rolle was früher einfach nicht existent war und vielleicht haben da einige,
Geschäfte Angst die Kontrolle über die Bevölkerung weltweit zu verlieren und deswegen versuchen Sie dann neue Gesetze zu kreieren
die uns alle wieder ein bisschen mehr unter die Kontrolle der Staaten bringen anders kann ich mir nicht erklären.
Gut wenn wir uns doch mal wieder den schönen Dingen.
Ich bitte darum.
Ja aber ist dachte das muss man auf jeden Fall auch mal angesprochen haben können wir mal wieder zurück zur.
Deine Rolle ist ja jetzt auch immer schwerpunktmäßig gewesen die eigentliche Gestaltung,
mit voranzutreiben warst du auch schon gesagt auch musikalisch zu kuratieren weitere Bereiche mögen jetzt da noch mit rein fließen worüber machst du dir,
Gedanken.
Wenn so ein Event ansteht wird z.b. die nation of Gondwana die dich ja auch wieder stattfindet was.
Was braucht es um diesen Ort zu schaffen an dem sich die Leute wohl fühlen können und daran erinnert werden können ist Freiräume dann doch eine tolle Idee.
Also so eine Veranstaltung fängt ja mal mit der Veranstaltungsabteilung anspricht,
ich mache mir Gedanken wo eine Bühne stehen könnte wie diesen also wo dann die Schallrichtung ist wo eine Bar platziert werden sollte also ich mache mir im Vorfeld,
eigentlich bei jeder Veranstaltung Gedanken über die Laufwege wie kann eine Veranstaltung funktionieren und wie bewegt,
die Masse an Leuten sich auf dieser Veranstaltung das ist erstmal das so fängt man an eine Veranstaltung zu planen also dass die Bar richtig steht dass die Bühne richtig steht das
der Eingang ist es ja meistens vorgegeben wo der Eingang ist aber dass das die Laufwege einer Veranstaltungen funktionieren,
das ist Basis einer jeden Veranstaltung und dann kommt da.
Öffne die richtigen Orte für eine Bar und die richtigen Orte für eine.
Das kommt immer auf ein bisschen auf die Location an aber also,
indoor-outdoor ist auch dann noch mal ein Unterschied aber das die Bar halt nicht gegenüber von der Bühne ist die sollte halt immer irgendwo an der Seite sein
dann ist der Zugang zur Bühne also wie komme ich an die Bühne ran komme ich von der Seite komme ich von hinten komme ich von vorne
das sind so also ein paar Meter die einfach sehr sehr entscheidend sind für das Funktionieren einer Veranstaltung,
so das liegt dann halt auch mal ein bisschen aneinander Location so und dann ist es halt wichtig dass.
Das Musikkonzept funktioniert also ich.
Oder alle nicht nur ich alle sollten oder machen oder Butter machen es eigentlich so dass du kriegst halt ganz viele Demo Sets,
zugeschickt heute per SoundCloud früher gabs immer noch Demo Kassetten die man sich dann anhören konnte und dann machst du dir halt Gedanken über das Musikkonzept wie baust du,
eine eine eine spannungslinie auf also fängst halt an.
Fängst halt an mit eher ruhiger Musik dass die Leute halt erst reinkommen und dann hast du halt irgendwo unten Peak mit.
Härtere Musik die wahrscheinlich in der Nacht läuft und dann geht's halt wieder ein bisschen runter und.
Wenn es gut läuft geht's zum Ende der Veranstaltung noch mal wieder hoch also der ist das musikalische Konzept muss passen.
Unter das belegt man sich dann halt für diversen Bühnen so.
Ja wenn das zusammenpasst also du brauchst halt so ein bisschen die Fähigkeit Sonderveranstaltung lesen zu können sowohl musikalisch als auch die bewegungsströme.
Was passiert dann was passiert als nächstes welche Musik kann ich zu welcher Zeit.
Was man bei Spinnen was man wieder so.
Mich kannst mal an so wir nennen es wieso auf der nation of Gondwana das ist so die Haupt Handfläche das ist so und dann musst du halt.
Bis in die Nacht das hochfahrende muss halt immer schneller werden immer schneller werden immer schneller werden bist du dann so zwischen 12 Uhr und 3 Uhr,
zum richtigen Techno alarm Nennig Zimmer.
Warum muss man das was kalt.
Weil es kalt wird weil natürlich du musst diesen Spannungsbogen aufbauen das irgendwann wollen die Leute dann halt richtig ausflippen und das ist in der Regel dann wenn
wenn es dunkel ist und die Lichter wirken und alles andere auch noch wirkt und,
dann macht es Sinn das in die Nacht zu verlegen.
Anstatt der Nacht wenn es kalt ist und die irgendwelche mit Musik laufen zu lassen dass es wird nicht funktionieren definitiv nicht du kannst vielleicht eine Bühne haben wo nur ambient music läuft aber du kannst keine Bühne machen,
oder einen Denzler machen wo du nachmittags Techno spielst und zur Nacht hin in den MEN Bereich Abdrift ist,
da gehen Leute alle schlafen und das ist ja nicht ziel des Ganzen sondern du willst ja dass die Leute möglichst lange ausgiebig tanzen können.
Ich mich jetzt für die Hauptbühne scandal Alternative.
Es kann eine alte ja aber da funktioniert ähnlich also wie gesagt du,
wenn du eine Emden Bühne machst dann solltest eine reine Ambient Bühne sein aber du kannst nicht irgendwann nachmittags mit Techno anfangen und dann immer langsamer werden in die Nacht hinein,
und zum morgen dann wieder schneller als es wird glaube ich nirgendwo funktionieren sondern du musst halt immer irgendwo den Pik setzen und der Peak ist bei so einer Veranstaltung.
In der Regel immer die Nacht dann kommst du halt runter.
In den morgen oder in den Morgengrauen wenn es dann wieder hell wird dann musst du eine andere Atmosphäre schaffen musikalisch,
das ist dein kommendes oder sollte es vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so harter Techno sein sondern es geht dann halt es wird ein bisschen sphärischer das ganze.
Dann über den vielleicht gehen dann auch ein paar Menschen schlafen kann auch mal passieren und wenn sie dann wieder aufgewacht sind kannst du dann eigentlich wieder so ein bisschen anziehen mit der Geschwindigkeit in der Musik,
so dass du dann halt zum Nachmittag hin noch mal so einen song von der Geschwindigkeit ist und Peak setzt und das dann noch mal wieder runter kommen lässt bis zum Ende der Veranstaltung.
Kannst ja den Dieter ist nicht eins zu eins vorschreiben.
CeBIT pro minute sie da an Start bringen sollen also liegt es Händchen an der Stelle quasi überhaupt erstmal an der kuratierung der richtigen DJs das heißt die muss man auch über längere Zeit,
kennen und sich mit dem Werk vertrautmachen hörst du das hörst du noch viel.
Ich höre ich dich viel Musik also gerade wenn es wenn es ins booking geht das sind dann so,
sechs Wochen zwei Monate intensives Musik hören also wiege ich krieg von ganz ganz vielen Agenturen weltweit Künstler angeboten und die die mich interessieren da höre ich dann,
mir die Sets durch also erst höre ich so in die Chats rein also spricht du hörst,
Tigerstern durch die sich sonst hät entwickelt und wenn du dann,
ein Musiker in die engere Auswahl genommen hast dann höre ich da durchaus auch mal eine Stunde oder länger mir sonst hätte durch und dann bastel ich das in ein Zeitfahren rein.
Irgend so so funktioniert das.
Obwohl das ja nicht bedeutet dass dann das Set so genau.
Nein aber dann,
bitte die du hörst dann wenn wenn du wenn du einen dir ausgesucht hast du hörst dann mehrere Sets von dem X ist dann Soundcloud dann guckst du bei YouTube dann guckst du was die Agentur dir von dem geschickt hat und,
wenn du dann dir sicher bist dass das passt dann packst du den erstmal in einen Zeitplan rein.
Und dann nimmst du die nächsten DJ möglichst den davor oder die zwei davor und die zwei danach und dann hörst du das so durch.
Also dass du fünf hintereinander weg hörst und.
Gustav noch zusammen passt.
Guckst du auch noch zusammen passt und.
War aber schlau auch falsch.
Weil manchmal traust du dann halt die Position weil du denkst naja das vielleicht,
passt ja dann doch herum und drei Stunden früher und schmeiß dann halt die die Zeitpläne noch mal kurz um aber so funktioniert das dass du so eine Zeit waren hierfür Sonnenstunden so eine Bühne machst.
Und das mache ich dann in der Regel für ein paar Bühnen es macht Spaß also so guckst du ein bisschen skeptischer hattest,
das ist eine große Verantwortung also definitiv beides muss passen das muss sitzen du kannst dann irgendwann nicht mehr verändern daran aber es ist macht euch durchaus Spaß,
so also,
es ist meiner anstrengend mit der ganzen Flut an Demos die du trägst und dich das schaffst du nicht so voreilig macht was meine,
Beratergruppe was das angeht ist jetzt nicht so riesig also die letzten Entscheidungen liegen das schon bei mir,
so das ist ja wann die die Verantwortung schon hoch und alles schaffe ich nicht durch zu fahren was ich da so geschickt Kriege ist Unglück.
Wie viel tolerant also wenn wir schon jetzt bei der Nation auf eine Veranstaltung hier quasi jetzt seit vielen Jahren,
aber Damian zum festen Zeitpunkt mehr oder weniger in einem eingespielten Rahmen stattfindet also auch gewisser Hinsicht eine hohe Vergleichbarkeit hat wie viel,
wie viel turnover hast du da sozusagen bei den DJs wie viel ändert sich
wie viel neue newcomer kommen da sozusagen zum Spiel wie viel old farts werden von Jahr zu Jahr weiter geschoben.
Also ich bin ja eine ganz treue Seele was sowas angeht also ich liebe das schon so ein Stamm,
von Musikern zu haben genauso wie auch in der Crew mit denen ich eigentlich jedes Jahr gerne wieder Zusammenarbeit so das ist die gehören halt einfach zu Familie dazu und
auf die baue ich auch und die bauen auch auf uns das sind so.
Andi an die zehn Musiker die eigentlich fast jedes Jahr wieder dabei sind und das auch seit vielen vielen Jahren so und das ist bis es dann halt so der Stamm.
Und um die drumzu kreiert man dann halt einen einen neues Programm jedes Jahr,
und was haben wir dieses Jahr haben wir ungefähr 90 90 ECTS die spielen.
Und du gehst du auf 10 Uhr davon vielleicht lass es 15 Uhr sein sind letztes Jahr dabei gewesen was heißt du.
Okay.
Aber.
Noch nie da waren teilweise waren die Haltung vor drei oder vier Jahren schon mal da so sind trotzdem ich glaub so.
20 15 20 die komplett neu sind dieser die noch nie gespielt haben aber es macht halt auch es ist ein bisschen einfacher geworden,
gerade für mich als bockert weil die Agenturen halt schon die Nation ist auf dem Fokus geraten so das war vor 10 Jahren vielleicht noch nicht der Fall aber die.
Agenturen würden halt schon ganz gerne dass wir irgendwelche Musiker von denen bei uns runter bringen das macht das verhandeln.
Da die Veranstaltung strahlten zunehmender Masse ab irgendwann soweit ja irgendwie immer da,
aber das waren auch andere aber gerade so in dem Zuge der letzten 10 Jahre wo viele sich dann auch final abgemeldet hat
von dem Markt seid ihr so ein bisschen übrig geblieben so ein bisschen wie die wie die Flure hat sogar noch länger als Diffusion würde sagen ja nächsten geht nicht weg
erhält dadurch auch noch mal so eine ganz eigene Strahlkraft sicherlich auch getragen vom Feedback der Teilnehmer das kann man sagen weil.
Die Gäste spielen in der ganzen Geschichte eine große Rolle.
Die Gäste spielen eine Rolle nicht zuletzt spielt aber auch glaube ich eine große Rolle dass Berlin sich stark verändert hat die letzten 20 Jahre und das Berlin sehr sehr viel internationaler geworden ist und
dass die Nation das nächste Open Air in der Stadt ist also das ist alle anderen sind deutlich weiter von der Stadt entfernt,
wir wir sind praktisch S-Bahn Ring der große S-Bahn-Ring sowas Mann bist du in 45 Minuten draußen mit der Bahn,
und wirst auch mit dem Shuttlebus abgeholt brauche ich mein Auto also es ist sehr sehr einfach zu erreichen und ja durch die Internationalität der Stadt.
Ist es irgendwie ein bisschen mehr in den Fokus gerückt,
wir mal also haben wir gar nicht großartig zum beigetragen das ist irgendwie ziemlich von alleine passiert vielleicht auch dadurch dass wir ein bisschen mehr internationale DJs buchen inzwischen als dass wir es früher getan haben,
aber wie gesagt die kommen halt auch von alleine auf uns zu und fragen ob sie nicht mal spielen können und macht halt deutlich einfacher.
Schon immer auf die auf die DJs Dieter ist ja so ein bisschen die die Rockstars eigentlich der,
der Techno-Szene gewesen was früher so der der interpret die Band ja oder auch mal die Solokünstler waren so die die die die direkten Bediener der Instrumente sänger ist zitterer,
hat dich das so um mit dem Techno ein bisschen verlagert auf einmal gab es diese hohe technische Reproduktionsfähigkeit,
über Schallplatten und heute läuft ja vieles auch komplett digital
und lange Zeit war das ja auch immer so ein bisschen so ein skeptischer Blick so ja wieso ihr später nur die musik von anderen Leuten und schiebt die Dinger hintereinander,
was was siehst du in in der Arbeit der DJs dies auch handwerklich den Unterschied macht sowas da einer kuratorischen Perspektive was macht,
und das macht vielleicht auch darum auch jenseits dieser handwerklichen Arbeit DJs,
aus und was tragen sie zu der Veranstaltung im besten Falle bei.
Ist essen.
Also als allererstes mal ich finde dass das Großteil von denen wirklich wirklich große Künstler und Musiker sind das ist also es ist nicht nur Platten spielen oder CDs auflegen es ist du brauchst halt
wirklichen Gefühl das Publikum mitnehmen zu können und das können nicht viele also das ist das sind es gibt,
tausende von DJs inzwischen wo aber,
nicht alle wirklich richtig gut sind also du brauchst du brauchst da halt schon Gefühl für das Publikum und für,
das was du da gerade mit dem Publikum veranstaltest und das deswegen gibt's wahrscheinlich,
inzwischen so richtige super Stars die es drauf haben.
Das zu können so also gab es vor 20 Jahren Sven Väth Jeff Mills und so ein paar andere sind sie inzwischen schon ein paar mehr aber ist ich glaube es zeichnet sich schon,
ist oder zeichnet sie aus dass sie das wirklich richtig richtig gut können das Publikum mitzunehmen oder,
dahin zu bringen wo sie das Publikum ganz gerne haben würden.
Was ist San Sebastian da konkret das handwerklich was du siehst meine wenn ihr zum die Mutti passt da ist ja dann sozusagen es sei denn es ist jetzt live bei einer Veranstaltung aufgenommen wurde.
Hätte du du hörst das schon also du hörst schon ob ob er ob der in seinen eigenen DJ das kann oder nicht das hörst du schwierig.
Den Spannungsbogen hinzukriegen also dass ich habe das ja eben erklärt anhand von wie baut man einen Spannungsbogen für eine.
Die Ansicht auf und so baut halt auch jeder DJ eigentlich einen Spannungsbogen für sein Zelt auf.
So als heißt die er fängt irgendwo an und hat dann mehrere Peaks eingebaut und der weiß die in in in der Regel wissen die natürlich vorher was Sie vorhaben also.
Die legen sich das auch zurecht so wann mache ich was zu welchem Zeitpunkt und dann kannst du drauf reagieren wie das Publikum mit geht oder nicht.
Und es gibt wie gesagt ganz ganz viele DJs aber nicht alle kriegen das hin diesen Spannungsbogen bis zur Perfektion aufzuarbeiten.
So und dann man muss sich da ein bisschen mit beschäftigen das.
Aber ist das nur die Auswahl der Musik was ich jetzt hintereinander Spiele oder.
Naja manche manche machen natürlich auch eine Show wenn sie auf der Bühne stehen aber Basis ist die Auswahl der Musik,
und wahrscheinlich die Reaktionsfähigkeit darauf wenn das was du dir halt vorher überlegt hast jetzt gerade vielleicht doch nicht so gut ankommt oder das Publikum noch nicht soweit ist dass du jetzt ein Pik setzen kannst in Deinem set
sondern diesen Kick halt noch mal um ne halbe Stunde verschieben musst und da.
Dann noch mal anpassen.
Noch mal anpassen.
Die Stimmung der Leute ans Wetter was auch immer dann gerade so passiert.
Genau ja regnet es ist jetzt vielleicht gerade das nicht angebracht sondern brauchst genau und gesagt das kann nicht jeder aber es gibt welche die können das.
Erinnerst du dich so an Sets wo du live mitbekommen hast wieso DJs auf solche Situationen reagiert haben dass sich sowas überhaupt in Worte kleiden.
Welche erinnere mich an ganz viele Sachen also ich erinnere mich auch daran dass DJs Ungarn unheimlich aufgeregt sein können vor irgendwelchen Sets oder denn
BMI Kind ganz ganz dringend noch mal unbedingt auf Toilette müssen weil sie irgendwie auf die Bühne kommen und sehen oh mein Gott was ist hierbei soll ich gleich spielen oh das ist jetzt ein bisschen zu viel für mich und ich muss noch mal schnell
ganz kurz,
mach mal 10 Minuten Pause oder sag dem anderen DJ muss zehn Minuten länger spielen weil ich muss noch mal ganz kurz irgendwas erledigen so und.
Sind da ja UPS wurde absolute Situationen schon miterlebt und.
Auch wirklich schöne Geschichten wenn wenn du halt siehst wenn du auch.
Teilweise die Panik in den Augen siehst wenn wenn die da hochkommen und
überfordert sind mit mit dem was sie da jetzt gerade vorfinden also im positiven Sinne überfordert sind so weil sie halt einfach geschockt sind oder von der von der Atmosphäre die da auf sie einprasseln.
Und das habe ich auch wirklich bei DJs erlebt normalerweise vor deutlich mehr Publikum spielen als dass wir es haben aber bei uns ist vielleicht eine andere Energie am Start.
Der Tanzfläche so also wurde halt auch jetzt schon paar mal gesagt das ist erstaunlich ist das bei uns halt.
Keiner sein sein Mobiltelefon in der Hand hat um zu filmen was gerade auf der Tanzfläche passiert oder den den den DJ zu filmen wie er gerade auflegt. Das ist also für euch ganz ganz oft so,
und wenn du dir so gut wenn du so YouTube-Videos mal guckst von so einem Megastars wenn die irgendwo in der Welt spielen,
die Hälfte des Publikums hatten Telefon in der Hand was das hoch hält und einfach nur filmt das interessiert die gar nicht zu tanzen die Filmen einfach nur noch den DJ und.
Das ist bei uns so ein bisschen anders in dieser alternativ Kultur,
so und deswegen also habe ich da schon lustige lustige.
Das interessant dass du das ansprichst weil ich hatte.
Ich hatte neulich neulich es gut auf Chris oder vorletztes Jahr of a nation of Gondwana mit Otto gesprochen der ja.
Eine der treibenden Kräfte der Diffusion Festivalisten macht er dann immer so bisschen den Urlaub bei euch,
und erzählte mir dass das jetzt gerade von Dokumentationsfilm gemacht habe verstehst du verdammt noch mal immer noch nicht gesehen habe übrigens noch mal rauskramen hätte sich in dem Zuge.
Videos angeschaut so von den ganz alten veranstalten.
Wär heute aufgefallen dass die Leute einfach anders getanzt haben.
Deutlich schneller fahren.
Nella hey ich weiß nicht intensiver wo.
Intensifier.
Also ein wilder Strudel und man merkt er da auch natürlich klar,
am Anfang seiner Bewegung ist das natürlich auch alles noch mal extrem viel familiärer und und man dass sich auch.
Noch viel mehr glaube ich bewussten in was für einer besonderen besonderen Moment besonderen Ort man sich gerade befindet war ja alles andere da draußen.
So anders ist Nahsicht ich kann mich auch noch an den Tag erinnern wo ich das erste Mal im Fernsehen in einer Werbung so ein Techno Beat gehört,
dachte so auch alles klar jetzt jetzt kommt es an so aber vorher war das die Musik die keiner kannte und die nur,
auf diesen Veranstaltung stattfand und von daher natürlich auch noch mal was ganz Besonderes war trotz alledem will ich jetzt auch nicht sagen dass.
Alles davon komplett verpufft ist das gerade die Veranstaltung die im schon bisschen länger dabei sind eben auch noch viel von diesem familiären behalten haben und immer wieder auf diese DJ Situation zurückzukommen.
Siehst du den Eindruck habe dass eine gute Veranstaltung sich fahren daran ablesen lässt wie sie
wie gering eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen den Sendern und Empfängern ist also oft ist es ja bei dir bei so einem übersteigerten DJ Pult
man kriegt das oft halt mit zu dieses oh ja hier unser DJ Gott der uns hier irgendwie das Glück in den akustischen Kübeln über uns ergießt und wir sind jetzt hier rum wie die Empfänger,
aber dass das und das spiegelt sich ja auch indem wieder was so jetzt über diese Nervosität und Panik sagst
das hast ja mitnichten so eine reine unidirektionale Sache ist sondern das eben letztlich auch die Party crowd genauso intensiv zurück
kommuniziert man sieht das ja auch an den Blicken und untereinander auch,
und das ja dann letztlich auch wieder dass das kreative Werke was jetzt von der Bühne ausgesteuert wird aber nicht unbedingt im Zentrum steht wieder zurück befeuert.
Ja richtig also wenn du wenn du jetzt bei so vergleichen bist und dir mal so diese ganz große Festivals anguckst mit also jetzt mal abgesehen von der Fusion die ich zwar auch ein ganz großes Fest will es aber
hoffe auf was für eine Ebene Torte DJs & Musiker gehoben werden das ist,
komplett was anderes als das was wir machen also die stehen da auf 20 Meter hohen Dünen weitab vom Publikum da gibt's den Graben dazwischen da gibt's riesen Bühne ankommen graben da kommt ein Zaun da kommt Publikum
und das Publikum hat dann irgendwie ein Telefon in der Hand und filmt die Bühne ab das ist,
sowohl bei uns als auch nach wie vor bei der Usern oder gab es auch schon gutes Beispiel ist es daher komplett anders dir
also ich oder wir sehen zu dass wir die DJs halt nicht auf so eine hohe Schild heben sondern dass wir sie,
auf einer Ebene lassen dass sie halt mit dem Publikum auch wirklich eins zu eins kommunizieren Kontakt bei uns kann das Publikum immer noch
an den DJ ran reichen und dem auch mal was zu rufen oder dem mal ein Getränk anbieten so das ist und,
ich glaube das ist ein inzwischen großer Unterschied zu diesem ganz großen Dingern du hast halt die direkte Kommunikation noch
da ist nicht einer eine riesen Wand zwischen den Musikern und dem Publikum sondern da ist noch eins zu eins Kommunikation und.
Wenn die zu uns oder auf dieser alternativen Festivals gehen,
dann ist es auch oft so das haben die sich ausgesucht die Musiker und die bleiben dann ganz oft auch noch das ist nicht.
Komm also auf den großen Festivals ist es halt die werden da hingefahren die gehen kriegen ihre bensels und gehen auf die Bühne spielen earset,
steigen wieder ins Auto ein und fahren ins Hotel zurück bzw direkt wieder zum Flughafen fliegen aufs nächste Festival bei uns und bei einigen anderen ist es so um die wollen nur spielen,
das heißt bleiben auch in der Regel und feiern dann noch mit und das ist eigentlich ein ganz ganz großes Kompliment also besser geht eigentlich nicht wenn du dann.
DJs halbe Stunde nach ihrem Set auf der Tanzfläche selber am Haus,
aber hast du eben noch mal gesagt hattest war das Eule meinte das ist ein Unterschied gegeben hat zwischen dem Tanz Verhalten von früher und heute
und wenn ich mir so alte Videos angucke dann kann es eine bestätigen also es war.
Lustige anzugucken wie früher getanzt wurde meiner Meinung nach wurde schneller getanzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen intensiver also heute ist das alles ein bisschen gediegener geworden.
Hoffen wir miteinander um einander rum.
Was.
Also was mir noch aufgefallen ist ist heute wird sehr viel in Richtung Bühne getanzt also siehst du wenn du von der Bühne runter guckst siehst Gesichter.
Früher war so das war egal das war Idee haben in alle Richtungen getanzt und so da wird auch der Wald angetanzt der hinter oder du du wo die Bar getanzt irgendwas wurde angetanzt.
Die muss ich vorher getan Sohn die Kamera von überall und das hat sich so ein bisschen es ist so ein bisschen ruhiger der Tanzstil ist ruhiger geworden und die Leute gucken alle inzwischen bisschen mehr kennen Bühne und also es ist schon bisschen.
Bisschen fixierter geworden ist kann ich bei uns also auch nicht nicht abstreiten dass die Leute schon sehen wollen was auf der Bühne passiert das war früher nicht.
Man kann immer auf jeden Fall gestalterisch entgegenwirken.
Durch das durch das Bühnendesign DZR und andere Faktoren Gestaltung weil ich gerade noch mal kommen aber vielleicht,
wird man auch noch mal erwähnen wir machen jetzt auf der sodium klassischen Fehler ein bisschen den Eindruck zu vermitteln gerade das DJ-Team wäre jetzt würde sich ausschließlich nur aus Männern zusammen setzen die Miss ja mitnichten so.
King ist mitnichten so also ich bringe da jetzt gerade schnell Musiker Monika Kruse ins Spiel also dies ist auch seit seid
25 30 Jahren dabei spielt auch immer bei uns und es ist eine von vielen sehr sehr guten Musikerinnen
die auch in diesem ganzen ja in diesem ganzen Party.
Was hat sie ja so ein bisschen entwickelndes da es gab immer so ein zwei die jetzt auch heraus starren aber es war ganz klar lange lange Zeit und ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch immer noch so ein Männer,
dominiertes und hast du das Gefühl das ändert sich in der Hinsicht sind.
Warum das so ist kann ich dir ehrlich gesagt auch nicht sagen arbeitest du siehst halt schon deutlich mehr Männer
Eminem in diesem Business oder in diesem in diesem Partyleben als dass Frauen da sind,
es wird jetzt so ein bisschen versucht.
The DJ sai.
Auf der DJ Seite natürlich auf der dieser Seite ist wird jetzt ein bisschen versucht das machen unter an um dir auch wir haben jetzt einen einen einen floor der heißt bei Birte wo wir,
ja wo wir halt so,
vielen Frauen wo oder wo wir viele Frauen mindestens 50% sollten es immer sein einladen auch da Musik zu spielen und.
Aber so im allgemeinen glaube ich schon dass Frauen es da auch so ein bisschen schwieriger haben oder schwerer haben die schwierige sondern schwerer haben in.
In diese Welt reinzukommen warum das so ist ich kann es Dir nicht erklären.
Es gibt glaube ich mehr Männer DJs als Frauen DJs.
So vom allgemeinen Eindruck her aber es werden auch durchaus deutlich mehr Männer gebucht als Frauen.
Hast du eine Quote.
Ich habe gerade keine Quote aber ich sehe es natürlich auch daran was und wie viel das hätte ich geschickt Kriege also sind
deutlich mehr Männer die mir verschicken oder auch Agenturen die deutlich mehr männliche DJs anbieten als das weibliche DJs angeboten werden.
Gestaltung einer Veranstaltung als ja auch.
Mehr nur anbieten als Musik natürlich.
Die Musik im Mittelpunkt in gewisser Hinsicht ist schon weil es schon besprochen haben strukturiert den Zeitverlauf,
begleitet das geschehen ist ja auch irgendwie die ganze Zeit da immer immer präsent egal wo man sich befindet man hört halt vielleicht lauter oder leiser
ohne Ohrstöpsel oder akustikkammer kann man sich da vorher nicht verbergen etwas anderes was bei euch,
extrem große Rolle spielt ist das Licht,
muss Weise generell die künstlerische Gestaltung durch Aufbauten durch Dekoration im weitesten Sinne.
Welche Rolle spielt das.
Bei euch wie geht's dir daran ist ja auch so ein Teil dem du sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit.
Fitness und und was soll die Gestaltung der Veranstaltung live.
Also wir haben es immer wohl kaum Ästhetik genannt weil der Raum eine gewisse Ästhetik bekommt die vorher nicht gegeben war und es ist,
wichtiger Aspekt bei uns also a.
Versuchen wir auf unseren Veranstaltungen oder was heißt versuchen wir arbeiten ohne Sponsoring das heißt,
warst du auf vielen anderen Veranstaltung auch da ist halt alles voll mit Sponsoren Banane und Logos geklatscht da haben wir von jeher drauf verzichtet weil
das halte den Geist einengt meiner Meinung oder unserer Meinung nach und deswegen haben wir sehr viel.
Wer hat auf die Raumästhetik bzw auf die Kunst gelegt war also von Anfang an schon mit Künstlern von der Kunsthochschule zusammengearbeitet hatte ich ja vorher schon mal erwähnt und,
es ist für mich oder für uns unglaublich wichtig also neben der neben der Musik,
das Licht oder die die Lichtgestaltung ist nimmt richtig viel Platz ein so und das heißt wir versuchen,
das was da ist zu beleuchten mit einzubeziehen und wenn es nicht da ist versuchen ist hinzuzufügen.
So also sowohl über der Tanzfläche also wir einen einen einen mehrschichten System zu schaffen.
Weil wenn du oder was heißt frei wenn du hoch guckst also mehrere,
Ebenen also ne das Bewusstseinsebenen oder wie auch immer zu kreieren dass du über deinem Kopf was hast und dann aber noch mal zwei Schichten darüber.
Irgendwas mit Licht zu kreieren was deine Gedankenwelt so ein bisschen ja inspiriert,
und dazu kommt dann dass du irgendwelche Punkte dir auch auf so einem freien Feld raus suchst die du.
Sowohl als landmark setzen kannst als auch als Orientierungspunkte dass die Leute da nicht komplett verloren gehen.
Sodass so also entweder brauchst du Wege Systeme Durchlicht,
oder du setzt halt einfach ein paar Punkte durch Skulpturen oder durch irgendwelche lichtgeschichten dass die Leute halt auch nachts Neuorientierung kriegen.
So oder haltet du machst eine Projektion auf dem See sondern dreidimensionale einfach.
We can.
Dückersweg NRW tolle Sache.
Ja ja.
Also ganz gut ganz großartig und nee das soll halt die die Sinne anregen also wenn nicht jeder will noch so einer Veranstaltung den ganzen Tag und die ganze Nacht auf
der Tanzfläche sein aus welchen Gründen auch immer manche Leute sitzen auch einfach stundenlang abseits einer Tanzfläche und wollen sich Lichtinstallationen angucken und ich finde es enorm wichtig
bieten zu können und es macht natürlich auch richtig Spaß sich dasselbe anzugucken und vorzubereiten,
und auch das ist wieder,
Teil des Gesamtkonzeptes sowas überlegt man sich halt vorher wie sowas aussehen könnte oder so irgendwie brauch halt auch so ein bisschen die Gabe sich das alles schon mal vorgestellt oder vorstellen zu können wie es hinterher aussieht.
Unterstreiche auf jeden Fall auch für diesen. Das ist so eine Party halt mir ist also eine Musikveranstaltung,
gesamt sensorisches Ereignis in der halt eigentlich alle Sinne auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise stimuliert werden Musik erreicht Anhalt irgendwie akustisch
optisch kriegt man durch Licht aber halt auch tagsüber meine die Nächte sind ja dann im Sommer auch vergleichsweise kurz also.
Viel zu kurzer müssen wir dann andere breiten ziehen um da mehr von zu haben aber du willst aber die Locations lake gleich noch schwerer,
man dieses Seiten schöner Begriff na also sozusagen so so so so so eine holistische Raum und Moment,
Erfahrung die man dort sammeln kann allein durch die anderen Leute die da sind was man da noch sozusagen auch an Inspiration.
Heranzieht sicherlich auch durch.
Drogen von denen man ja immer wieder hört dass sie gepflegt zum Einsatz kommen auf solchen Veranstaltungen mischt rührt sich da sozusagen so eine so eine Suppe an in der man einfach tauchen kann.
Ja es gab mal jemanden oder es gibt jemanden in meinem Umfeld der kreierte mal diesen Begriff Realitätsflucht Hilfe
oh und das trifft es eigentlich immer noch ganz gut mein der Begriff ist sehr sehr alt aber das ist ist trifft eigentlich immer noch zu 100%.
Auf das zu was wir eigentlich da machen
so das ist für für ein paar Stunden oder für 2-3 Tage der Realität zu entfliehen und was wir dazu beitragen können ist eigentlich die Musik das Licht,
und die Location zu bieten und für den Rest sind jeden Menschen in der Regel selbstverantwortlich in das kriegen sie eigentlich auch ganz gut hin und,
der Realität zu entfliehen für gewisse Stunden und das ist glaube ich das was es auch nach wie vor auszeichnet diese,
Vormonat.
Ja das sind dann außerdem Momente wo der noch zerkratzte dieses jugenddebatte sogar so ganz
täglich reinkommt bei der Gedanke und gehe genau in in diesem höchst privaten persönlichen Erleben von allem wo man einfach mal abschalten will und eben nicht
der Realität konfrontiert werden will man muss ich der früh genug wieder stellen
in dem Moment der Gedanke jetzt würde ich irgendwie eine Polizeistreife rumlaufen und dann in irgendeiner Form eine Bewertung treffen von dem was man jetzt da gerade
tut was zwei Tage später ohnehin schon wieder Vergangenheit ist das ist wie oft du das.
Es ist absurd ja also jetzt mal ganz unabhängig von diesem Punkt Drogen oder nicht Drogen durch die Musik und das was wir jetzt eben beschrieben haben durch das Licht durch all das,
kommst du ja sowieso schon in einen an einer Art Trance Zustand und wenn.
Da möchte man keine Polizei in einer Uniform Besitz bringt dich nicht in diese erweiterten Sphären die du ja eigentlich erreichen willst wenn du so eine Veranstaltung besuchst,
das ist total kontraproduktiv wenn da da eine bestrafte Hundertschaft vor dir steht,
dann ist es vorbei weil da fühlst du dich er bedroht als dass du dass dir sowas Sicherheit.
Das kann mir auch keiner erzählen dass da eine eine eine eine Hundertschaft die dann plötzlich vor dir auftaucht einen ein Sicherheitsgefühl der dir hervor bringt das ist einfach das ist nicht der Fall.
Sondern du bist ja eigentlich gerade wenn alles gut läuft in einem.
Glückszustand was da der braucht es nicht mehr zu als.
Als dieser Veranstaltung oder diese Party dann brauche ich keine Hundertschaft.
Ja und vor allem Sicherheit gibt einem Jahr.
Was anderes so also ich meine es halt sie die alte Geschichte auf vom Set und setting also wie gehe ich selber rein und in in was bin ich letztlich eingebettet,
ich finde eine gute Veranstaltung ist in dem Moment entstanden um dieses Gefühl hat so man man man ist.
Privat unter Fremden also Ostritz nicht so ganz genau also month man hat ja jetzt nicht mit jedem allermeisten kennt man,
mich hat man vielleicht mal gesehen mein Gespräch geführt aber Welt bei vielen tausend Teilnehmern ist ja natürlich klar dass man immer nur ein Bruchteil der Leute wirklich kennt aber es spielt ja dann auch irgendwo keine Rolle weil du einfach
wirst unsere Sonne Sonne Sonne,
auch sprachlose Kommunikation führen kannst über den Dancefloor hinweg man man lächelt sich halt einfach an und weiß okay alles klar ja wir haben jetzt hier im Wesentlichen auch dieselben Ziele es gibt eine gewisse,
Verantwortung die man auch füreinander spürt es heißt man weiß ja auch in dem Moment wo irgendwas passieren würde,
ist das man nicht auf dem Boden fällt und liegen gelassen wird sein dass das einfach genug Leute da werden die sich sofort um die man auch kümmern wird.
Ja dazu kommt aber also was heißt da dazu kommt inzwischen auch diese,
Veranstaltungen wir sind ja ganz anders abgesichert als dass wir es früher irgendwann mal noch gewesen wären wir haben inzwischen ein halbes oder ganzes mobiles Krankenhaus auf dem Acker
wir haben einen wearnes Team auf dem Acker wir haben zeigt ja Teams auf dem Acker wir haben die Feuerwehr auf dem Acker,
die Polizei ist in der Regel nicht weit das ist sowohl bei uns als auch bei der Fusion der Fall die sind in Laufnähe.
Also und es gibt einen permanenten Kontakt zwischen all diesen Bereichen und es ist es ist ja.
Nicht so dass wir uns dann nicht in Sicherheit wiegen können oder.
Es ist einfach der Fall dass es so ist wir sind alle oder die meisten inzwischen sehr sehr gut aufgestellt wir nehmen ja solche solche Punkte auch ernst.
Wird es ist ging ja nicht blauäugig an so einer Veranstaltung wann wenn irgendwas passiert dann wollen wir auch abgesichert sein und das sind wir auch.
Also wir die Flusen auch,
das ist nicht so dass da irgendwie aus 300 km Entfernung irgendwer gerufen werden müsste sondern dass wir sind inzwischen sehr sehr professionell aufgestellt walterfang,
so also das ist gerade die Rettungskräfte es ist war früher so.
Da musstest du einen Krankenwagen rufen das konnte teilweise mal bist du nach halbe Stunde oder Stunde dauern inzwischen rufst du die auch aber die sind auf dem Feld das dauert keine fünf Minuten bis da jemand ist,
ganz egal was drauf.
Da steht heute mein RTW rum.
Steht dir steht im RTW wir bei uns gibt es Ärzte im Schichtdienst die sind einfach mal da.
Und die sind auch wirklich gerne da also wir sind das ist ja auch in der Diskussion bei der bei der bei der Fuzion die sagen ja auch nicht über was für eine BE
bekloppte Veranstaltung die haben ja auch genau das gleiche die haben auch RTWs da die haben auch,
Feuerwehr am Start das ist ja nun das ist dies ist und gerade von diesen Leuten also hörst du auch mal wieder ganz ganz viel Lob,
dafür wie gut wir organisiert sind so und wie gesagt also da kann es passiert ganz selten was.
Aber wenn was passiert sind wir drauf vorbereitet also was heißt selten also Fußball Heizung Schnittverletzung in der Flasche getreten das ist natürlich dass das haben wir.
Kleinkram.
Tangram so aber alles andere.
Außer Angebote wieso was hast du gerade zeigt er also Leute die sich sozusagen auch so um den seelischen Zustand von Teilnehmern kümmern können wenn Bedarf ist habt ihr auch schon eine Weile dabei.
Nee nicht nur weil also bei uns noch nicht ne Weile haben wir jetzt dabei und hat sich jetzt.
Ausgezahlt ist es eigentlich auch eine gute Sache.
Was geschieht da da sind dann Leute die aus welchen Gründen auch immer gerade für den Moment nicht klarkommen mit der Veranstaltung mit sich.
Und oder anderen und die können sich dann entweder freiwillig
bei den Leuten melden das sind in der Regel ausgebildete Psychologen Trauma Psychologen und die kümmern sich dann um diese Fälle.
Und ich glaube wir haben es letztes so jetzt seit 12 Jahren bei uns wir haben das vorher so bisschen offen gehalten,
da hatten wir wussten wir immer sind Leute da die können das aber jetzt haben wir eine feste Anlaufstation und das hat.
Ja das war sehr positiv sowohl des DAK als auch die Ärgernis Leute als auch die Feuerwehr haben gesagt wir möchten diese Position ist immer besetzt haben weil das sind halt ja Trauma Psychologen die.
Den Leuten dann helfen können mit einer.
Situation klarzukommen die geht gar nicht um gar nicht unbedingt mit der Veranstaltung zu tun haben muss sondern irgendwas ihr.
Irgendwas sein Beziehungsstreit so.
Schreit irgendwas aus der Kindheit kommt hoch hatten wir auch schon so und dann hast du halt nicht bezahlen da.
Und der nimmt dich dann kurz mal raus und ist einfach nur für dich da und kümmert sich um dich.
Und ja oft ist es dann so das dauert dann halt seine Zeit und meistens können die Leute dann aber auch weiter feiern danach.
Wie nimmst du denn so die Gäste war also mit viel über.
All die Leute und Gruppen gesprochen die halt vorbereiten die Dinge machen und da bieten.
Wie hat sich denn so das Publikum nimmt er das Publikum deiner Meinung nach teil und welche Rolle.
Spielt das Ganze in dem Gesamtkonstrukt Veranstaltung.
Naja also Publikum ist schon so ein wichtiger Faktor Sonderveranstaltung.
Na ja ist schon klar ich weiß jetzt etwas unspezifisch gefragt.
Nein ich weiß natürlich was du meinst also.
Ja ich weiß das noch nicht genau was ich meine aber wenn du schon weißt was ich meine dann leg los.
Publikum also ich muss jetzt wieder von uns reden ich kann natürlich auch von meiner Erfahrung auf anderen Veranstaltungen erzählen aber Publikum ist
na klar ist das A&O für fürs Publikum macht man es in aller erster Linie mal macht ein bisschen für sich selber aber man macht natürlich vor allem für das Publikum weil das Publikum soll der das was du gemacht hast auch gut finden und
wir sind auch hier wieder in indir ganz glücklichen Situation dass wir ein ganz ganz tolles Publikum haben also
jetzt auch nicht nur bei dieser einen Veranstaltung sondern das begleitet uns über diese 25 Jahre die wir das oder 30 Jahre die wir das jetzt schon machen,
dass wir praktisch nie Ärger hatten,
also wir hatten ich glaube die Schlägereien die wir auf den hunderten von Veranstaltungen die wir gemacht haben kann ich an an weniger ja oder an einer Hand abzählen und ist es.
Das A und O eigentlich und.
Wenn die mitgehen und wenn die dabei sind und wenn die sich nicht benehmen wie wieso Vollassis sondern die kommen sind sehr höflich.
Dem in der Regel ihren Müll wieder mit und.
Ja wir haben beachten eigentlich die Grundsatz Regeln des Zusammenlebens,
wie ein Zusammenleben mit ein paar tausend Leuten für ein Wochenende funktionieren kann und es ist großartig dass du sehen dass das,
dass du halt nur einen ein Wochenende in tausende von glücklichen Gesichtern gucken kannst und.
Ist keine Aggressionen gibt und keine,
ja keinen keine keine Ellbogengesellschaft mal für ein ein paar Stunden in in in in einem Jahr oder auf einer Veranstaltung.
Oder weißt ja sicherlich jetzt nicht nur gute Musik zu spielen und schönes Licht aufzubauen,
wird ja sicherlich auch andere Maßnahmen ergriffen haben über die Jahre um das sozusagen auch zu befördern oder zu ermöglichen dass ich das eben unter diesen doch Extrembedingungen auch so ausspielen.
Ja aber natürlich ist auch dass die das Publikum muss natürlich auch erstmal die Bereitschaft mitbringen sowas überhaupt.
Haben zu wollen also die du du willst die ja nicht umerziehen so die die die die denken ja auch nicht dass sie jetzt.
Die Sau rauslassen können sich benehmen können wie.
Soll ich mal auf so einfache Sachen was dass ich so dieses
Mülltüten gleich am Eingang mitgeben so also hier alle wollen dann vielleicht auch ihren Müll einsammeln aber dann keine Mülltüte dabei wohin damit funktioniert nicht
nächste Mülltonne in 200m und dann dann klappt das halt nicht das sind natürlich immer so Kleinigkeiten die man so reinschieben.
Das sind Kleinigkeiten die Handys ist natürlich auch eine Erziehungsfrage so ein bisschen über all die Jahre so also der wird das sind jetzt auch nicht nur wir das gab halt von Anfang an,
bei vielen Gruß.
Das Bedürfnis okay das kann nicht sein dass jetzt 2000 Leute kommen und die alle ihren direkt mitbringen ihre Sofas von zu Hause mitbringen die sie nicht mehr brauchen und das alles auf dem Acker liegen lassen also das geht ist es ja auch so dass wir uns,
untereinander also was du eben schon meintest mal mit der clubkommission sowas gibt es natürlich auch unter Openair Veranstaltern oder gab es früher vor,
dass wir dann halt gesagt haben okay wir müssen hier so ein paar Grundsatz Regeln gemeinsam schaffen und unter den Voraussetzungen können wir das und dass,
und dann war halt z.b. diese Sache mit den Mülltüten wir bieten Mülltüten an und das Publikum kann dort ihren Unrat entsorgen und in Container schmeißen und das haben wir dann,
über all die Jahre kommuniziert dass das halt so zu laufen hat und oder halt das Flaschen aufn gesammelt werden und das bitte wenn wir schon Mülltonnen anbieten dass diesen Mülltonnen auch benutzt werden
und das sind halt so die so eigentlich in jedem Haushalt normalen Dinge die du halt dann einfach auf Sonntag hat oder auf so eine Party transformieren musst.
Bei mir siehst du sie an Müll festmachen aber plötzlich meine Frage eher in die Richtung wie kommuniziert ihr.
Den Gästen die hat sich auch das jetzt im Wandel der Möglichkeiten der Kommunikation der Ende hat,
wo wie früh auf welcher Art und Weise stellt ihr diese Verbindung zu den Leuten her die letzten Endes ankommen werden.
Naja erstmal über unsere Social Media.
Also sprich über Facebook und unsere unsere Website also Mailingliste gibt's inzwischen nicht mehr und diese Telefone Anrufbeantworter gibt's inzwischen auch nicht mehr.
Szalai.
Und Flyer gibt es auch nur noch bedingt und,
du blickst halt AGBs mit einem Ticketkauf,
also das heißt weißt du selber wissen alle AGB's heißt ich habe verstanden um was es sich handelt und ich beachte folgende Regeln so und die ihre diese Regeln haben wir halt auf der Website stehen.
Und die kommunizieren wir halt auch über Facebook so und.
Wie viel Nähe kriegt der da sozusagen hin.
Wir kriegen da schon ziemlich viel Nähe hin also beim wilden Mann kann uns ja auch anschreiben man muss uns ja nicht also wenn wenn du irgendwas wissen möchte,
Duschen gibt es warmes Wasser dann schickt man uns eine Mail oder eine Nachricht und wenn man es nicht verstanden hat und kriegt dann,
zu 100% euch auch eine Antwort darauf was wir bieten und was wir nicht.
Und hat sich das so gesteigert über die Zeit also wird es angenommen.
Ich glaube fast eher dass es früher mehr gewesen ist als heute.
So also das ist so ist wird es sehr gut angenommen aber es ist für euch viele
das sind viele erfahrene Openair Gänger dabei die haben die müssen sich diese Fragen schon gar nicht mehr stellen in also wenn dann kommt halt höchstens noch mal eine Frage nach dem Auto Ticket
aber wie eine Veranstaltungen oder wie man auf eine Veranstaltung lebt ist inzwischen wegen deinen Hintern nicht bekannt für die meisten ge.
Alu profile.
Alles alles fireprofi.
Wasserhund Dauerthema ist rund um den Techno.
Ja auch so die damit verbundene drogenkultur kein Geheimnis das so.
Mit elektronischen Tanzmusik auch eine.
Neue Generation sowohl von Wirkstoffen sich auf dem Markt angefangen von hat aber auch ein anderer Umgang damit sich etabliert hat wirst du das so.
Begleitet die beobachtet du das.
Also ich würde mal sagen dass es jetzt nicht unbedingt Primera mit Technomusik
toonhud sonorous weiß ist eigentlich schon das gibt's ja schon deutlich länger wenn wir jetzt mal an an
Woodstock denken oder an die ersten großen Hippie Open I ist war ja immer irgendwo was hatte das immer irgendwo was
Drogen und Bewusstseinserweiterung zu tun also es ist vielleicht jetzt durch technol stärker in den Fokus geraten.
Aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen dass das jetzt oft auf den Bereich von Technomusik beschränkt ist sondern das hat allgemein was mit Musik zutun und
ja der Bewusstseinserweiterung durch oder mit Musik eine andere Sphäre zu erreichen,
Hunde was den Techno angeht.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht dass es wirklich neue Drogen gibt seitdem es Techno gibt also sowohl Ecstasy als auch Speed und Kokain,
gibt's alles lange vor Techno und auch,
kiffen allgemein ist seit mehreren 10.000 Jahren glaube ich verbreitet in der Kultur ist es die Frage ist er danach
Warum rückt das in den Fokus und warum wird das so thematisiert obwohl das Teil unserer Kultur ist
und da müssen wir glaube ich ein Ansatz finden also klar ist Musik und Drogen.
Wird immer in einem Atemzug genannt unnötigerweise wie ich finde.
Ja trotzdem ist es natürlich Teil dieser Partykultur.
Es ist Teil dieser Partykultur ich würde jetzt nicht davon ausgehen dass 100% aller Partygänger auch Drogenkonsumenten sind aber es lässt sich sicherlich auch nicht von der Hand weisen das da
Drogen konsumiert werden auf diesen Veranstaltungen und.
Ich gehe doch an Dich ganz offen und ehrlich mit um es ist halt einfach so und lass die Leute machen mein die meisten.
Stehen
wie sagt man so schön mitten im Leben in der Arbeitswelt warum sollten Sie sich das nicht gönnen oder zumuten auch mal
ein paar Drogen zu nehmen wenn sie im Feuermodus sind,
also für mich ist das sehr sehr normale und natürliche Sache und da ist halt eher die Frage ob ihr mit den verboten.
Die momentan bestehen weiterkommen.
Und ob man da nicht irgendwie mal eine andere Drogenpolitik anstreben sollte das ist also eine gesellschaftliche Frage die ich als Techno Party Veranstalter ja eigentlich nicht wirklich beantworten kann.
Sind Politiker und Ärzte eigentlich viel mehr gefragt als dass ich gefragt bin so ich wie gesagt ich kann es nicht von der Hand weisen das passiert aber es ist ein gesellschaftliches ist auch kein Problem es ist halt ab,
gucken wir mal restriktive Drogenpolitik bringt uns nicht weiter,
irgendwo also gucken wir mal nach Mexiko so wie viel Tote ist da gibt gerade,
und da muss man du kannst die Drogen nicht verbieten weil wo ein Angebot ist ist ordnen oder wo die Nachfrage ist gibt's auch das Angebot dafür und das in meinem Bruder sollst oder.
Es hatte noch keinen positiven.
Beleg dafür gegeben dass ein Verbot von Drogen auch zu Verzicht auf Drogen führen würde das ist halt aber nicht so und da.
Oder auch nur geordnete Verhältnisse.
Nein das ist das passiert aber nicht.
Ich meine auch ist ja auch eine Begriffs Fragen also ich meine es wird auch Bier
getrunken und ich will mir fast mal vorstellen ihr habt am Ende mehr Probleme damit das Leute zu viel Bier trinken als dass sie zu viel Joints rauchen.
Richtig ja ist so also ich meine.
Also wir haben da jetzt keine Probleme mit aber wenn du mal auf sonnensohn normales Dorffest guckst ich bringe jetzt mal das Beispiel,
Blütenfest in Werder was so ein kleines kleine Ortschaft in der Nähe von Potsdam ist ein massives Problem mit Alkohol Konsum und dadurch bedingter Aggressivität
sag mal im Kiefer,
der Garten Joint geraucht hat da vorne ist eine Schlägerei wir machen erstmal mit da wird er dir Sachen zu ich habe gerade andere ich habe keine was anderes zu tun als mich in der Schlägerei einzumischen also
ich kenne wenig Leute die Cannabis konsumieren die Bock hätten auf eine Schlägerei also das ist das widerspricht sich.
Das geht nicht nur für Cannabis denke ich mal.
Es ist niemand und deswegen also man braucht dann anderen Ansatz also,
und die Bierkonsum,
ist in der Gesellschaft allgemein anerkannt und da kann man sich mit Rüben wie viel Biere man geschafft hat zu trinken bevor man umgekippt ist wird dir bei Cannabis kaum passieren und,
Warum ja warum sollte man den Menschen also auch alles verbieten wir haben so viele Verbote.
Und es werden immer mehr Verbote warum gibt es nicht irgendwo was was man auch mal ein bisschen lockern kann weil wie gesagt es bringt auch alles nichts.
So also die die wenn wir jetzt mal Bier Drogen im allgemeinen Begriff von Drogen zusammen nehmen dann.
Konsumieren wahrscheinlich 80% aller Mitteleuropäer irgendwas soglow
oben sind halt verboten und das ist halt was Böses geächtet und Bier ist halt und Bier und Wein und Alkohol ist Halten oder Zigaretten können wir auch dazu nehmen ist halt in der Gesellschaft anerkannt und
seit eigentlich total das.
Ich würde sogar soweit gehen zu sagen das ist Sonne diese psychedelische Drogen Kultur also LSD Pilze diese ganzen Wirkstoffe die jetzt,
bewusst Bewusstsein,
verändert das mal so ein komisches Wort Ich will Witze fast sogar sagen Bewusstsein fördern sind weil einem einfach mal andere Dinge.
Gewahr werden und vielleicht auch manchmal zum psychologischen Effekt haben dass man sich vielleicht auch selber mehr öffnet also gerade bei Ecstasy,
das ist ja auch eine Droge ja sozusagen so aus der mal bei Merck eigentlich als Hunger
Wirkstoff quasi entwickelt wurde um Leute vom Essen abzuhalten,
die Wirkung ist ja auch Teil des Spektrums was dann sonst noch dazu kam war dann sozusagen unerwünscht unerwünschte Nebenwirkung dann war das dann sozusagen als Medikament in dem Bereich keine Option ist ja dann in den
im psychologischen in die psychologische Arbeit mit eingeflossen weil man einfach gesehen hat dass Leute sich daneben
mehr öffnen können aber,
Jungs Probleme mit Sidra kann das ja zum Einsetzen hat darüber dann wiederum sein Weg gefunden war aber auch ein gewisser Hinsicht so ein bisschen auch an ein Baustein in dieser ganzen,
ja Loveparade der Name ist sagt es ja schon so dieses Liebe Ding ja man man man kommt sich irgendwie näher öffnet sich denkt das hat schon auch seinen Beitrag gehabt dazu was wir heutzutage so als Techno Party oder überhaupt als
Party wahrnehmen.
Definitiv als meinte die Ecstasy ist verbunden mit Techno irgendwo und.
Das hatte jetzt glaube ich nicht unbedingt einen negativen Einfluss sowohl als auf die Konsumenten als auch auf die auf diese ganze Techno Bewegung also eher so dass man ja.
Sind wir wieder bei Doktor Motto Friede Freude Eierkuchen und genau das ist es ja mit meinem Mann gefällt sich um Hals und hat.
Hört sich ganz ganz starke Gefühle und.
Schon immer mal sagen.
Was ich dir schon mal sagen wollte,
nee und wie gesagt warum nicht also mir fällt da gerade noch Pervitin ein sowas auch als Beat bekannt ist in der beim Militär heute noch.
Für die für die für die kriegsflieger eingesetzt dass die halt möglichst lange durchhalten da ist es dann okay.
Aber wenn wir oder wenn wenn die Gesellschaft ist so konsumiert ist es dann nicht mehr okay also meintest es.
Kann mir dann auch keiner plausibel erklären warum das gut ist auf Speed Kriege führen zu dürfen aber nicht feiern gehen zu dürfen also das ist ein bisschen absurd.
So ne also wir können festhalten und Drogen werden konsumiert aber jetzt nicht nur auf,
Techno Veranstaltung oder Musikveranstaltungen sondern werden von der allgemeinen Bevölkerung genauso genutzt und benutzt und werden von Regierungen auch genutzt und benutzt Vivi.
Von allen anderen auch deswegen pro Trolley sierte Drogenpolitik und einfach mal drüber nachdenken.
Ja liebe geht ja auch durch den Magen.
Was vielleicht auf ein bisschen übersehen wird ist so dass sodass Essens und Stück weit auch das Getränkeangebot ja auch noch Rolle spielt ihr gibt euch da.
Ganz schön Mühe habe ich so den Eindruck ist auch ganz interessant dass sollen insbesondere in diesem Open Air Bereich auf seine ganz eigene essence,
Darbietung Skulptur entstanden ist da gibt's viele
diese herumziehende Gruppen mit hochspezialisierten Wagen die sich dann auf bestimmte Essensangebote auch spezialisiert haben und durch die Lande tingeln.
Ja wenn du mal zurück denkst 20 Jahre was hatten wir früher wir hatten ja nichts ne wir hatten eben
scheiß Shop so unter mehr gab es ja eigentlich nicht und nimmt scheiß Shop gab es dann irgendwie vielleicht mal so ein bisschen Kuchen und ansonsten gab es da te
so vielleicht noch mal einen Kaffee dazu und das hat sich inzwischen wirklich spezialisiert sodass es gibt einen einen einen einen einen einen riesen,
Vulkan an festival.de fanden Händlern die inzwischen echt,
ein wirklich außerordentlich gutes Angebot haben also das ist vom vom Rinderbraten mit Klößen und Rotkohl
bis zu jeglicher Art von von exotischen Speisen die dort angeboten werden und das sind inzwischen wirkliche Profis
Hasi machen im Winter wintermärkte oder Weihnachtsmärkte und die ziehen das ganze Jahr über von Festival zu Festival also ganz egal ob sie es Musikfestival ist oder Volksfest
und erstaunlich gut also die Qualität ist inzwischen erstaunlich gut was das Essen angeht,
an die haben auch festgestellt dass hier mehr Qualität sie zu fairen Preisen bieten desto,
so und ja das ist ein ein ein Riesenfeld geworden inzwischen und die begleiten uns halt.
Begleiten also begleiten uns über Jahre aber begleiten halt auch.
Alle Outdoor-Aktivitäten im BH inzwischen in ganz Europa also dazu kriegen auch Angebote von von Franzosen oder von Holländern die ganz gerne kommen würden und.
Also von burger-biss bis alles alles was du dir vorstellen kannst frisch zubereitet.
Das wird sich positiv auf die ganze Veranstaltung.
Das wirkt sich positiv auf die ganze Veranstaltung aus so weil früher hat meiner gedachten ja also da ging die Veranstaltung aber auch nicht ganz so lange da konnte man mal 12 Stunden ohne Essen aber inzwischen sind Festivals ja mit Anreise und Abreise schon vier bis fünf Tage
und da musst du halt vernünftig essen also da brauchst du gutes also kein Trash food mehr so denn du willst halt auch gut essen,
das Duo Avaya wiegeliegen besser du es bist du besser kannst du auch feiern gehen so und ja ist eine sehr positive Entwicklung finde ich also.
Wirklich schön und Assi geben sich.
Echt verdammt viel Mühe inzwischen sowohl bei der Dekoration von ihren Shops oder von ihren Verkaufs wegen als auch bei der Qualität ihrer Essensausgabe oder ihre essen
und
inzwischen auch wirklich nachhaltig also teilweise kommen die da mit mit Porzellan also nicht Porzellan aber mit mit richtig Besteck und richtig Tellern an und haben dann auch spülstationen wo sie.
Das alles wieder reinigen können damit sie keinen Plastikkörbe mehr ausgeben müssen oder halt wiederverwertbare Mais Schachteln oder weiß der Geier was also das ist eine sehr positive Entwicklung in den Bereich.
Mathe was so Nachhaltigkeit betrifft da auch ansagen.
Es ist wünschenswert ja also wir sagen definitiv keine keine Plastikverpackungen die dann einfach weggeschmissen werden also das sollte schon irgendwas aus
hier oder irgendwas kompostierbare sein und
was wir inzwischen auch machen weil wir versuchen den Müll zu trennen also wir haben letztes Jahr und vorletztes Jahr glaube ich auch schon
ganz Mülltüten aufgerissen und Mülltrennung getrieben.
So nachträglich wird.
Wir haben weil den wir festgestellt haben dass mit die Leute ihre Mülltüten voll kriegen verschwindender halt auch oft Plastikflaschen und Glasflaschen drinnen und das haben wir letztes Jahr haben wir das
großräumig ausgekippt und getrennt.
Oha was für eine Arbeit ist ja überhaupt.
Aber du das ist natürlich auch für die Umwelt und B ist es natürlich auch einen Kostenfaktor so also meins ist.
Fallen auch für Besucher Flaschen die abgegeben werden pro Kilo Müll und.
Da macht es natürlich einen großen Unterschied ob du da irgendwie noch mal 10000 Flaschen aus du mir aufgesammelt hast oder nicht.
Von der Größenordnung läuft das dann ja okay.
Ja so in der Größenordnung doch dass du also wir versuchen vor Sonderveranstaltungen überall über Getränkehändler in der Stadt Leer Kisten zu kriegen.
Die wir dann befüllt zurückgeben können,
und sind wir fahren LKW Weise Plastikflaschen Weg die dann nach ich glaube nach Halle gibt's so eine sortierstation und dann gibt es zwei Monate später eine Abrechnung für.
Gib mal einfach alles rein und missioniert das heißt man merkt auch dass du sagen auch die sonstige Wirtschaft sich auch auf solche Veranstaltung ein bisschen eingestellt hat oder ist das im Angebot gewesen.
Die sonstige Wirtschaft in Form von Aldi die Wirtschaft.
Also sowohl jetzt die Entsorgungswirtschaft als auch.
Die ja natürlich also das ist es ist mein es ist ein Wirtschaftsfaktor geworden,
also sowohl bei da wo wir
die Veranstaltung machen als auch Festival insgesamt in Deutschland also es gibt ja diese ganzen großen Rock am Ring oder so und das sind
dies gibt Verleihfirmen die machen ja nur noch sowas die meisten aus Holland wir haben ja auch schon in paar Mal in Holland gearbeitet du weißt die Holländer sind sehr gut was so mobile Raumsysteme angeht
was ist ein ein Camping Volk diese Witze hatten wir ja schon in den 80ern im deutschen Fernsehen,
so und die sind richtig richtig professionell was sowas angeht und das ist,
allgemein Aggregat Verleih was containerverleih,
kommt ganz viel aus Holland oder holländische Firmen die in deutschen Markt besetzt haben und es ist Kristen,
also wirklich alles kannst du Lion was du für Sonne Meer warum brauchst.
Ich kann mir vorstellen dass dieser logistische an Teilnehmer ist eigentlich nur angekratzt haben ihr vielleicht auch noch mal einen Themenschwerpunkt darstellen sollte.
Zuschuss für dich.
Noch mal auf was zurückkommen was uns ja auch uns beide konkret verbindet aber in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein Phänomen geworden ist,
davon Techno Kultur
und Techno Party Kultur sprechen sind da ja zwei Dinge zusammengekommen dir so auf den ersten Blick vielleicht erstmal gar nicht zusammen gehören nämlich die Nerd Zähne konkret haben wir ja
zusammen was hat 99 mal so eure Vorstellung von Open-Air-Party.
Und unsere Vorstellungen von Computer Congress zusammen gekippt und dabei kam das Chaos Communication Camp hinaus.
Emblaze gar nicht so viel von meiner Rolle sprechen ich will aber noch mal vielleicht kannst du ja mal so schildern wie das so.
Von deiner Seite aus,
aussa mit deinem Hintergrund damals und deinen Erfahrungen bis dahin wieso diese dieses drehende digitalien,
auf euch zu gerollt kam und was das was sich daraus ergeben hat was du da gesehen hast.
Das muss ich halt ein bisschen unserer beider Vergangenheit wohl net mein das war natürlich,
als diese Anfrage kam du kanntest uns von von diversen indoor Veranstaltungen von Bar besuchen von der nation of Gondwana und kamst dann halt mit der Idee auf uns zu,
sowas doch wirklich mal für die Computer Community zu machen und
dadurch dass wir halt eigentlich mit dieser Community nie was zu tun hatten war es sehr schwer und vorzustellen was denn die Bedürfnisse sein könnten und ich glaube für die Computer Community war es.
Fast unvorstellbar.
Überhaupt auf ein Open Air gehen zu können um sich dort für den ein Wochenende oder eine Woche zusammenzusetzen und auf dem Acker zu hacken,
sorgende ist dir war noch nicht soweit wie wir heute sind aber ich kann nicht erinnern alleine diese.
Internetverbindung dort hinzukriegen damals in den ja Ende der 90er war mit diesem riesen Funkturm den wir da aufgebaut haben um eine Richtfunkstrecke von,
paulshof bis nach Berlin hinzukriegen und da gab es dann die erste ich glaube wir hatten 50 m Glasfaserkabel wo extra noch ein Spezialist aus Frankfurt angeflogen werden musste der diese Glasfaser dann verbindet.
Was weiß ich wohin der die verbunden hatte ich bin ja keinen ich habe keine Ahnung von sowas aber es war eine überaus interessante Erfahrung,
und wir mussten uns erst mal zusammensetzen was brauchen wir wir brauchen großes Zelt für brauchen eine Internetverbindung das ist das Haag Center da sitzen dann ein paar hundert Hacker was machen die da das war für uns komplettes Neuland
wie für euch komplettes Neuland war dass wir gesagt haben wir brauchen da ein bisschen buntes Licht,
wo alle gesagt haben was brauchen wir ein buntes Licht wir können doch solange wir weißes Licht haben ist doch alles gut hauptsache wir sehen was,
und dann also diese Budgetverteilung damals nein wir brauchen keinen buntes Licht das Kostgeld dann brauchen wir es sowieso nicht.
Was das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Nein du nicht aber die Community und als es dann 1500-1800 waren wir beim ersten Camp glaube ich und.
Teilnehmer.
Teilnehmer und.
Dies war eine ganz ganz tolle Erfahrung und also auch sowohl für uns als auch für die für die Community,
dass wir halt gesagt haben das müssen wir jetzt wiederholen und machen dass er inzwischen ist V VI Camp dieses Jahr.
Das ist ja.
Zweimal hat Landsberg zweimal Finowfurt einmal Ärger Mildenberg ist S6 Kampfhund.
Wenn man sich das heute anguckt im Vergleich zum wirklich ersten Mal wo 100 bunte Lichter da waren und die Rakete dann dazu kam und inzwischen ist es eine riesen Veranstaltung mit,
ich glaube 100 verschiedenen selten die alleine wir oder zur Verfügung stellen,
und die weiteren paar hundert zählt wieder von den Teilnehmern noch aufgebaut werden und also eine Materialschlacht inzwischen wirklich
also wunderbar so aber das ist gab
beim ersten irgendwie ich glaube wir hatten einen Container mit zwei Duschen für die Frauen und zwei Duschen für die Männer inzwischen haben wir da ganze Zelte stehen
die sich nur mit dem Thema Duschen beschäftigen und Wasserleitung und stromverteilungen und.
Man könnte sagen es ist eine kleine Erfolgsstory geworden so.
Ja weiß ja auch nicht nur so eine es war ja so zwar nicht nur dass die Partykultur so zu den Nerds kam sondern die nerdkram er dann in der Folge auch in die Party.
Indie Party Kultur richtig also.
Hört sich das ausgewirkt.
Wie hat sich das ausgewirkt also mein Dispo die Überschneidung waren anscheinend immer schon da nur wusste keiner davon
und wir haben uns gegenseitig an in eine neue Welt oder in eine neue Welt herangeführt und inzwischen oder was heißt inzwischen im Zuge dessen sind auch ganz viele von den Hackern.
Auf diese Techno Veranstaltungen gegangen und gehe ins heute noch und,
das ist wohl eine inzwischen oder ist es eine eine sehr große Vermischung beider Szenen geworden und.
Vorteil von allen Beteiligten und dass die Unterschiede sind,
nicht mehr so gegeben ich meinen auf dem Camp laufen inzwischen auch Veranstaltungen im Seiten oder im Beiprogramm die sich mit Musik beschäftigen und also
so Atem Beauty gab es damals und Datum Beauty ist inzwischen
du kannst du camp ist inzwischen ein ganz großes Art und Beauty geworden und es wird nicht mehr drüber diskutiert wie viele bunte Lichter aufgebaut werden sondern oder ob überhaupt sondern nur noch wie viele
und es läuft elektronische Musik im
Programm 5 Tage lang in der Nacht und nicht nur auf einer Bühne sondern auf zwei oder drei Bühnen und,
ja die Teilnehmer vom.
Kongress oder vom Camp sind auch regelmäßige Teilnehmer auf irgendwelche elektronischen Festivals in ganz Deutschland geworden also jetzt nicht nur bei uns sondern auch die süddeutschen gehen auch irgendwelche Techno Veranstaltungen Süddeutschland und.
Gute Sache.
Also auch infrastrukturell was geändert für euch.
Für uns wir wissen dass wir Internet brauchen im Backstage inzwischen
ja gab es ja früher auch nicht aber natürlich ich meine wir haben natürlich auch die Vorzüge dieser Technologie Welt zu schätzen gelernt
mein.
Dadurch dass wir halt dann die Kontakte gekriegt haben in dieses in dieser Welt singen wir die Mailinglisten an die uns dann damals aufgesetzt worden von Leuten aus dem CCC und es ist halt heute so
dass das Internet bereitgestellt wird vom CCC Umfeld und
dass wir technischen Support kriegen wo immer wo immer es geht,
Beratung kriegen von von Leuten aus dem CCC Umfeld oder.
Ich denke die anliegende der außen etwas weiter gelagert als man vielleicht am Anfang auch gedacht hat na ja sowas vorher so ein bisschen als separate 10,
wahrgenommen wurde überschneidet sich ja an manchen Stellen jetzt nicht nur so aus welchen technischen Gründen heraus weil er braucht das was wir vorhin schon diskutiert haben also Freiräume
erhalten Freiräume auch schaffen ja das ist ja auch etwas was auf dem battinaatham Kongress schon immer bewegt hat und natürlich dann auch auf dem Camp
das man ja auch dort temporär so ein multisensorisch and Raumschaft in zunehmendem Maße in mir ist auch mit diesen
Einflüssen aus der Partywelt als auch viele Lichter ist auch viel Kunst Kultur da gibt es einen Partyraum da wird das alles quasi mit rein gewoben
uneben dann auch die entsprechenden Denkräume bereitzustellen dem daneben auch so dieses
dieses konkrete Freiheit erleben und diese Realitätsflucht Hilfe die bitte einen an der Stelle auch.
Bazzi bereitgestellt das Leute auch so bisschen wie das auch so nach sondern nation of Gondwana oder hier im anderen
großen schönen Festival ist sodass man sonst das Gefühl hatte oh jetzt ist alles vorbei
jetzt muss ich wieder hier in dieser in dieser andere Welt wie warum ist das immer nur 5 Tage und und und der Rest 360 und nicht umgekehrt
und
und es ist noch mal vertiefen zu wollen also auch hier zu der Kampf um die Fusion wird ja dann zurzeit auch auf breiter Front geführt auf der Club hat sich da jetzt mit eingebracht aber auch schon in den Jahren vorher
bist jetzt auf der.
Auf der Schule noch dieses Content entstand na das jetzt etwas was bei der Nation die er viel kleiner ist so jetzt erstmal keine Rolle spielt Diffusion sozusagen als als ja
heißt ja auch so eine Kulturkosmos es wird den hervorragendes war der daneben einfach sich eben auch aus sehr vielen unterschiedlichen Galaxien
ernährt eben mitnichten sich nur auf Party und Musik und feiern und tanzen bezieht gibt's ja auch die Theaterwelt die da
Jan Einfluss hat viele andere Gruppen auch und daneben auch jetzt
mit dem Content was esse seit 34 Jahren gibt da so ein Zelt in den Anhalt Vorträge stattfinden vocation gemacht wie du auch die wattiert wird ihm über Freiräume was sicherlich in diesem Jahr dann wird auch wieder erheblicher Focus sein wird.
Denker sind auch paar Sachen zusammen gekommen die eigentlich schön sich immer aus dem selben Bereich ernährt haben.
Definitiv also das ist ja das hat eigentlich zu zusammengefunden was eigentlich zusammengehört also und was,
irgendwo nicht klar war uns allen aber inzwischen
kann ja fast ja eine schon gar nicht mehr unter den anderen ohne den anderen existieren also schon existieren aber die Überschneidung sind einfach riesig geworden meine siehst es ja auch an den Teilnehmerzahlen beim Kongress jetzt
konkret und was für.
Was für eine Publikums Erweiterung ist da gegeben hat in in in den letzten Jahren das ist.
Meine sogar mein Mann ist Baden-Baden früher nur wirklich.
Spezial Computer Nerds die dorthin gegangen sind ist es inzwischen einen einen einen riesen großes kulturelles Spielfeld geworden aus allen Bereichen kommen da Leute hin und.
Gab es damals Teilnehmerzahlen von drei dreieinhalbtausend sind wir heute bei,
bei 18000 und das ist,
spezialisierte Computerexperten wie es früher gewesen ist die in ihrer kleinen Welt von der eigentlich damals kaum jemand was verstanden hat sondern es sind wirklich Kulturinteressierte und
die Vorträge haben sich auch dahingehend sehr das Spektrum erweitert und
ja es ist ein eine riesengroße Community geworden die irgendwo auch so ein bisschen zusammengewachsen ist aus verschiedenen unterschiedlichen Szenen die es vielleicht vor 20 Jahren noch gab so und.
Ja
Ja andre, so ein bisschen zum Ende ist noch etwas eingefallen dass man hier vielleicht noch mal abschließend.
Anmerken sollte hast du irgendwelche Wünsche.
Dinge von denen du gerne möchtest dass sie noch besser laufen.
Da bist du mich gerade auf dem falschen Fuß da fällt mir jetzt gerade gar nichts mehr zu ein nee eigentlich nicht also würde mir jetzt nicht so einfallen.
Ist ja auch alles ganz gut gelaufen mal sagen also.
Es ist alles wunderbar gelaufen.
Ne Menge Spaß und zwar mal sehen dass das vielleicht die Überhitzung der Gesellschaft sich auch wieder einfängt in der nächsten Zeit.
Definitiv also wenn ich mir was wünschen kann dann ist es wenn wir jetzt gerade weil wir so auch so viel drüber geredet haben ist es natürlich dass es ein gutes Ende finden wird mit den Verhandlungen da oben in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und das diffusion,
die Schussen bleibt wie wir sie alle kennen und das da jetzt nicht irgendwelche über motivierten.
Ja jetzt Leute denken dass sie da der freien Kulturszene in Deutschland einen Strich durch die Rechnung machen.
Das ist eigentlich das was wir uns für uns alle nur wünschen können weil sollte das durchgehen,
ist da glaube ich ein ganz ganz großes Tor aufgemacht für alle anderen Kulturveranstaltungen in Deutschland auch und ich glaube,
nicht dass irgendwer meinem Bekanntenkreis da irgendwie sich das wünsch.
Oder das auch nur gut wäre für den Rest der Gesellschaft dessen muss ich die Gesellschaft an der Stelle auch mal bewusst werden.
Na gut dann machen wir jetzt mal ein Deckel drauf vielen Dank Andrea für die Ausführung ja und das war's heute.
Mal wieder von mir von CAI seid versichert andere Themen werden
auch bald wieder den Weg in diesem Kanal finden auch das Thema der Party sind Partykultur was ich finde was viele Dimensionen hat wenn wir sicherlich auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise mal wieder aufgreifen aber.
Das war's erstmal für heute ich sag tschüss und bis bald.